this is now going to be day four coding
on the
Moa give it a second for the streams to
warm
good let
me do a little promo for the
day welcome
just about to get started
here um couple cool things we'll start
while the stream gets warmed up a little
bit I'll start with a couple cool things
couple results from the last day or so
uh then what I'm going to be coding on
today which is stuff I was working on
last night and uh we'll go from there
I'm probably going to try to be live
for getting started a little late I'll
try to still do seven hours we'll Target
7even
hours
so few cool things to start out
with so we have this where is it
projects we have this
sweep of the continuous control
environment that I started working on
last week I've Le left this running for
a very long time this has 335 completed
runs uh each run is a minimum of 500
steps per second a 500 million steps
total excuse me so that means that this
experiment has been training for well
over 150 billion
steps huge amount of training data
that's
like I don't even know how much data
that is that's a lot of data uh if each
OBS is a kilobyte which is it a
kilobyte might be a little less than a
kilobyte if it were a kilobyte it would
be 150 terabytes
right yeah 150 terabytes of data anyways
huge huge amounts of data
so this graph here is from the hyper
parameter sweep that we ran with all
these different experiments uses the
carbs algorithm which is from M Bui U my
integration of this algorithm
and it has automatically found us some
very good solutions to this problem
so I going to figure out a little do a
little bit of analysis on this while the
stream warms up um going to see if I can
figure out why we have these interesting
patterns and also i' just like to say
that if this point here is remotely
correct uh this has absolutely crushed
the environment
so that amount of data was was actually
incredibly useful for tuning something
this good so we'll do this analysis live
and you'll get to see the process for
this um I want to start with looking at
this point right
here interesting this actually this
curve is still going up very quickly so
possibly this can even get better over
time this specific set of hyper
parameters uh let's see if there's any
Shenanigans going on in the process
these curves the value loss is very high
that's a bit
concerning everything else looks mostly
reasonable the value loss is very high
this is a little bit
odd although this could be indicative of
just Um this can happen when training is
learning very quickly this can just
happen there as
well let's see
if we're going to and I see we have a
few folks on YouTube so I'm going to
spend a few minutes on this experimental
analysis because this is a really cool
result and then we're going to go
straight into the uh the madev and today
we're going to be coding uh 15 abilities
that we decided on on stream yesterday
and maybe we'll get some animations
behind them but it's going to feel like
a proper MOA by the end of the
day uh so with this analysis here I want
to see what the hyper parameters behind
this
were see if these look reasonable to me
or if there's something insane going on
a very large batch size
interesting in fact possibly I should
make this allowed to be much larger
because increasing the batch size seems
to consistently
help very low clip coefficient is kind
of
weird low entropy but that's not
terribly bad very low
Lambda is kind of odd reasonable
discount Factor reasonable gamma uh low
but reasonable learning rate this is
reasonable reasonable mini batch size uh
this ratio of batch size to mini batch
size is a little weird because it means
you have many updates on the same bit of
data and where do we have EPO update
epox 3 so this is a lot of updates on
stale data which is odd very odd so
these hyper prams are not insane but
they're a little bit W they're a little
bit wonky to me I'm surprised that this
is the one that does so well
next thing I want to figure out here is
I want to figure
out so when you get a graph like this
right this gives you a huge amount of
information about the environment um you
can see first of all how hyperparameter
sensitive the environment is this is one
of the continuous control environments
that we developed on stream next week uh
last week so you can see this is very
hyperparameter sensitive different
configurations lead to wildly different
results
here if I
check it seems like there are a lot of
overlapping runs here
right is it just me or there like a lot
of overlapping
runs it looks like there are a lot of
them right here that are
identical and I can see a couple
different colors here as well so that's
actually very odd we should not really
have experiments that are identic to
each
other so this could potentially be a
glitch with carbs it could be rerunning
the same experiment repeatedly that
sounds pretty likely to me uh or there
could be something weirder at
play Let's just grab
um here we'll we'll need um to well very
annoying that you can't
like there's no like link option here
we'll we'll click one of
these and then we'll go back to
sweeps we'll go back to WB sweeps and
we'll click another I just want to see
if it's launching with identical hyper
parameters multiple trials because it
should not be allowed to launch multiple
different experiments with um with the
same hyper
parameters so let's figure out what's
going on with
this so we click this one over here
let's click like this one over
here okay so if I scroll down we should
see that we have
exactly the
same we have exactly the same reward
curve here right exactly exactly the
same steps per second is not exactly the
same these are two different experiments
right
but they're getting exactly the same
results so I imagine that they're going
to have the same hyper parameters let's
see and it's going to be very weird if
they
don't
260k 8 BPT Horizon 8 BPT Horizon entropy
o28 entropy o28 okay so there is a weird
thing going on with carbs it looks like
G Lambda 0.7
let me just make sure 8 8 yeah okay so
somehow carbs is relaunching the same
experiment let me check time steps 069
069 yeah so carbs is relaunching the
same experiment multiple times so that's
just a bug with the algorithm uh we will
have to adjust that we're not going to
do that right now we're going to do
mobidev but uh I will include that in
the the Tweet here
um because this is a nice bit of
progress and people us usually like uh
the content on carbs this is a very very
powerful hyper tuning parameter
algorithm as soon as we get uh finish
getting the bugs out of this this is
going to be absolutely insane
for uh this is going to be absolutely
insane for the RL
Community let's
do this
plot two days
one
4090 and uh we use two CPU pores only
uh
complete
okay and we'll add the Star Puffer thing
and then we'll do
Mev if you haven't already if you want
to go ahead and Star Puffer lib it helps
me out a whole TCH a whole
bunch this is where all of my stuff
lives all open source
set so welcome
everyone we're going to go back to
Mev
um when we last left the environment
gift well I know the gift is on Twitter
so I'll show the the gift that we got
from yet last night um just a quick
render of the
so we have Minions that wander around
the creeps they have basic creep AI we
have a b basic few abilities there are
Towers the towers hit you they do damage
you can kill the towers creeps will
fight each other creeps will fight
Towers kind of looks like a really basic
mini MOBA
right and what we're going to do now is
uh at the end of the stream last
night we uh we kind of
co-designed some hero abilities we want
this to just be a mirror match 5v5
with support mid top bottom and jungle
rolls and what we're going to do is
we're going to implement the mechanics
that are required for all of these
abilities things like stuns slows
teleports and so on and um and auras and
stuff like that and then we're going to
implement the individual
abilities environment is currently 600
lines of cython the goal is to make this
whole environment done in no more than
12200 lines of scyon so so this should
have to be uh pretty compact we just
want to keep this to be a relatively
small
project I'm going to start by putting
this over here make sure it's not
covering
camera okay so things that we have to
implement for this um we need to
implement attack damage we already kind
of have that uh HP per uh per agent
maybe some sort of template for
that heal AOE
heal uh that's not that
hard AOE
stun not that
hard what
else ranged attacks that's already uh
already able we have to implement some L
distance
checks we've got to implement damage
over time lots of stuff okay good
starting
point I bet we can get all this done
today and then as soon as we get
this I'm surprised you're using top and
bottom Lane conventions instead of safe
and off Lane I actually have not played
very very I don't have that much time in
mobas I've played maybe like 50 hours of
DOTA and uh low few maybe few hundred
hours of League not even uh basically
barely however long it takes to qualify
for ranked like that plus a little bit
not that much um I played a ton of MMOs
and a ton of other games but not many
mobas so my vocab here is going to be
just a random hodge podge of DOTA and
League stuff uh and if I do anything
that weird or like doesn't make sense
from a game design perspective having
played more of these let me
stream okay
so we probably
need some
additional attributes here
need difference is safe and off safe
Lane is always matched against the
enemy's off Lane versus Vice Versa
bottom Lane is matched against bottom
Lane yeah okay I yeah yeah I remember
that okay so yeah on the DOTA map right
it's on the DOTA map it is uh it's
usually The Meta is 2v V one is it two
yeah it's 2v one on one side and then
it's 1 V2 on the other side usually
whereas in League it's usually uh 2v2
bottom right and then 1 V one top 1 V1
mid and then jungle dis jungle right I
am basing this off of the DOTA map not
the league map if that helps um but as
for what meta the agents discover that's
entirely up to the reinforcement
learning agents right and of course
influence by other decisions we make in
coding this
thing okay so uh we need to add a bunch
of stuff to The Entity struct here
um I got to figure out what actual
attributes we need so this needs to have
float move speed safe Lane is meant to
get gold for carry yep off Lane is meant
to stop them from doing that yep from
what I can see now from what I can see
you're doing now you're pitting carry
against carry which break
convention uh carry against carry is
league
right Carrie versus carrye is
League well okay here let I'll take a
second and you can tell me if there's
something weird here so I've lifted the
listed these as top bottom mid and stuff
but like I'm not assigning agents to
Lanes it's going to be up to the
reinforcement learning agents who goes
into what Lane probably at this start
they're all going to just go down mid
and then eventually they'll learn other
stuff um yeah DOTA has two in safe and
and oh wait DOTA has two in safe and off
and one in mid am I completely wrong
here I thought there was one in off and
then there's a jungler no or am I
totally wrong
there what's the DOTA what hold on
RoR both lanes jungling is in a rooll
they gutted it okay is that relatively
new or am I just
dumb possible I'm just
dumb Fringe option okay
so let's ignore the titles here right
just ignore ignore all these titles tell
me if this composition of teams if it
makes sense and if you or if there's
something that you think can be made
more interesting um I
made the idea here is there is a
character that has supportive utility it
has an AOE heel it has a stun and it has
a hook a pull there's a character that
has
uh that's like medium squishy not like
not super tanky and that does a ton of
burst DPS also brings a stun there's a
tanky is character that has uh that has
like a good engage there is a scaling
character that's a squishy and then
there's a character that has very good
clear as well as assassin type
abilities that's sort of what I came up
with I guess I modeled it a little model
it's modeled off of a hodg podge of Le
and DOTA I guess since I've played more
League uh I probably leaned more towards
that though I did also take some of
these things from the stream last
night specifically I was thinking of
Lena for Mid huder thresh for the
support the top was like a juggernaut or
a Garen bottom was like a Dr or an ash
and then the this position I took like
nocturn as an assassin
type well we're not going to they're not
they're not even going to be titled
anything
um if this makes sense though game
design
wise well I have to implement all this
stuff anyways and we'll see like we're
not really going to know
until it would be pretty hard to make
this thing fully multiplayer and I don't
think the stream is large enough to get
a full 5v5 anyways um though we could
try to like play test the
thing bottom would be better as a tank
IMO but it would
work if I make bottom a tank there's no
squishy there like the top is designed
as the top is kind of designed as a tank
he's got a self
heal not super tanky I guess wait is he
not super
tanky oh yeah the top should be more
tanky than it is now I don't have
anybody with high HP this should be high
squishy this is like an
assassin this is a
tank me I could label them like that
right
tank
DPS just like Assassin
this is like
burst and then this is
support maybe that makes it less
confusing okay I've had a little bit of
time in the back of my I had to think
about the abilities while I was talking
through that
um the one thing that's a little tricky
with these is we need to have well here
slow uh stun is
easy stun is
timer jug doesn't typically have high HP
or fit the tank roll somewh like necros
or Centaur Ray one or maybe maybe work
better as a model somebody in the Stream
yesterday like liked J Juggernaut as a
concept um I didn't build him quite the
same way as Juggernaut classically is I
gave
him I gave him a self heal for sustain I
gave him a channeled AOE damage over
time that's like the spin to win and uh
I gave him a engage a heavier like
single charge Target engage damage over
time is what I was thinking we also have
to implement all this stuff which is the
hard part
that's actually necros to a to a t okay
well then there you go it's that
then if I'm designing something that
ends up being one: one for an existing
character in a MOA it's probably a good
design so stun just needs a timer slow
needs a
percent um
we also need uh there's a move speed
buff I think there's really only one of
do
sent uh
int
timer we need timers and stuff for all
the Buffs
what other stat things did we come up
with a damage over times are not going
to be
handled in quite the same way this is
fine nuke stun heal hook I think that's
all we need to add to this base thing
to we'll set all of these in the uh the
reset or
wherever okay so here is where you have
the
players we set the base move speed to
agent speed
um that move
percent is going to
be 1.0
right I guess it's not a
percentage but
whatever here A Move timer zero stun
timer slow percent yeah these are all
zero and actually we don't need this low
%c because this is a slow
is uh is a move modifier so we can
actually just go with the move
percent and we can get rid of this
additional variable
here and instead of percent we'll just
do
here we need to start implementing some
abilities do we need slow timer then
yeah it's the oh wait
slow uh we need move timer I guess
technically move
timer yeah it works as move
timer well there are two ways to
implement stuff right um
reason the way that you'd Implement
auras is different from the way that you
would Implement like on hit damage over
times that like linger so it kind of
depends which way I'll leave it as move
timer for now
there a move timer and a stun timer
we'll leave it like this for now we
definitely don't need move and slow
timer though you're right about
that
um okay and I think we just start going
to skill
here now we're going to have to soup up
attack because a lot of these AOE and
stuff are just going to be calling
attack in a loop you've got two move
[Music]
timers
Loops move timer stun
timer
okay
I don't know if you can do default
variables in
syon incorrect handling these don't look
good let's assume that we
can't
so I guess we'll just have to set them
manually it's
okay inst stun
um maybe attack
[Music]
returns maybe attack returns a player
star a
pointer maybe we return a pointer to
the okay I think I know how I'm going to
do this it's just I have like the the
way that i' I've defined arguments and
stuff is kind of gross
that'll just get better though with some
so we have skill
attack let's just Define
um which is basically just this portion
of it
right it's just without the Mana
cost
so PID Target
PID and then instead of uh 200 this is
damage
and then when you do skill attack here
this should just
be AOE attack PID Target
PID
200 and you also have to do the Mana
check
right
so players get C def entity star
player we subtract the Mana costs and
then we do the AOE attack
right it's
fine I'm building on these as Primitives
because we can essentially use
uh we're going to essentially reuse this
for a bunch of stuff I think though I'm
going to have to handle this there's a
weird team check in attack that's going
to make it a little
not um um bur
ability single Target
stun the thing that's that's taking me
time here is I don't want to add a whole
bunch of arguments that can't have
defaults apparently I don't think scon
has good support for defaults so I don't
want to add like stun equals zero so on
and so forth and have a giant attack
function so what I think I'm going to do
instead
is this
attack is going to
take I could pass entity star here
instead of a
PID
right I could pass entity star
here let me try it this way let me just
see what happens entity
star
player ntid
Target and that way I can add stuns and
stuff more easily so get rid of this
we're going to do this check separately
no longer need this
and we can
do this is
fine uh we're going to have to change
this from respawn to
spawn I think that these do need pids
don't they let me see oh but it's fine
because it's in the yeah yeah yeah this
is we're good so we can do respawn
player oops no it's
Target and kill
Target and we'll just make all the
functions take uh entity Stars
there isn't something weird about
passing entity stars to functions is
there
pointer I think I can pass the point
around would you what's this would you
recommend someone learn computer
science and a bunch of fundamentals
before learning a language no you would
you learn them jointly um you're not
going to be able to conceptualize any of
the stuff that you see in the books
without actually implementing it in code
so I generally recommend people spend
like you're going to have to do a little
bit of study on Basics before you start
but um 80 like when you're new like 80%
of your time building very very basic
simple things and like 20% of your time
on formal
learning it's my
recommendation okay so I like this
attack function let's make a heal
function
and this team check is a little weird
because this is the only thing that we
even need it for
right you can pass a pointer just be
sure the formatting is correct yeah so
the thing I was getting confused over um
yeah no problem uh Everett the thing I
was getting confused over is if so let's
say that you I pass entity player I
think this is the thing I'm getting
confused over if I pass entity player
instead of entity star it passes by
value so it will make a copy under the
hood I think that I think that that's
how it
actually
um do I have that
right I seem to recall there being a
reason I never pass pointers to
functions in scon I only return them
from functions
do you have debugging capabilities in
your IDE uh I have very good debugging
capabilities for python uh I don't have
good debugging capabilities for scyon
because Tech like there isn't as good of
a debugger for it
this I mean I can just make a little
test for this right let me just make a
little test because I don't want to
refactor all this if I'm like have
something fundamentally long wrong about
the uh the language
C test PX let's
do uh test
struct
view let's do player
star or like this and then we'll
[Music]
do cdef player
star um player
I can
do player
dot uh Health equals
10 and then I can
do
def C
def void
mutate player star player and I can do
player. Health Plus equal one and then I
can do mutate K and I can print player.
Health
right quick run debugging session just
to check the value is not just copy when
passed in yeah so that's what I would do
normally but because cython transpiles
to C and then it compiles uh it's a
little awkward debugging scyon it's one
of the things I really wish were
better normally I would just put some
break points in in Python I just PD or
whatever
seg
fault
well are you not allowed to just make a
struct like
this you have to Malik
this obnoxious that it won't just
allocate stuff stuff on the stack for
you okay 11 that's what we wanted right
so it does work what the heck was I
doing before that was like screwing me
over
I think I was just being stupid before
because this definitely works you can
totally just plat pass around pointers I
think I was being stubborn and I didn't
want to be passing around pointers so I
think I was doing this before I think I
was trying to pass around just player
and then obviously that's a pass by
value so I think I was just being stupid
all okay so actually this makes
everything way simpler
um I still like this I still like having
these Getters here just
because uh if you try to index directly
and do free to get the an personand
you're screwed because it'll make a copy
with pointers it should be a lot easier
to lower processing time yeah uh well
the pids are kind of like pointers right
player ID is an integer that indexes
into the struct that tells you where the
thing is so it's kind of the same thing
um but this will definitely be a lot
easier also I don't know how long you've
been around this um but this program
here this environment is going to be
running at well over a million frames
per second by the time I'm done with it
not rendering but a million like State
updates player State updates per second
by the time I'm done with
it that is what is required for it to be
awesome for reinforcement learning and
I've done it for several other
environments so all of this bumbling
around does eventually get somewhere
typically
we'll think about these team checks
later but for now it's going to be you
don't want to heal your enemies and then
it's going to be Target
float
Mount
good I kind of prefer just clipping it
though I can do target. Health Plus
equals amount and if Target health is
greater than Max Health then you just
decrease it yeah that's
better okay so now we have our heal
function
as for our AOE
attack get rid of this
player entity star
Target loo damage be interesting if the
models could the models could heal
enemies making for some strategic
Brilliance once the models are trained
um wouldn't that just make it really
hard to get off AOE
heals like wouldn't that just make like
your AOE heal ability that you want to
be useful in a team fight not useful in
a team
fight like what is a situation in
which having that be a thing would be
good I think it just kind of Nerfs the
heck out of AOE
healing Target
PID oh you don't need Target wait do not
need so this is the center Target
here hey J hey JBL welcome welcome back
I should say I remember you are you
trying to make the gameplay mooba unique
or modeled after existing
mobas uh I don't particularly care how
original or unoriginal it is I just care
that we have something that works that
is relatively interesting uh that we can
use for RL
outnumber the enemy for more heals on
your
team promotes group cohesion and
effective
positioning it could
gauge did DOTA and League allow your I
don't think DOTA and League
have they don't let you heal enemies
right though I guess that's to prevent
briefing I will consider it it will be
considered let's get some of the basics
implemented
entity and it's going to be player
Target damage very nice I'm actually
yeah I'm liking these pointers way
more we'll see if they cause any other
bugs but these pointers are very nice
nice I really really wish that scon
didn't have pass by value so I could
just remove the pointer syntax and it
could be an
entity but they took this thing from C
instead of from python they could have
gone either
quick all my stuff is on uh jars 534 1
as well on
X
see okay Twitter's been quiet the last
couple of
days it's been a crazy week in the
US
understandable Okay so we've got this
AOE attack
uh I could very easily make this AOE
attack
um I could just make this
right and and I could
do uh
if why write it in
scon seems a little obscure which makes
collaboration difficult which is what uh
I something I assume you're going for
it's actually the least obscure thing
for the ML and AI Community
because athon is very close to python on
and it eliminates the entire piine
Shenanigans layer so the piy Bine
Shenanigans layer is a huge huge pain
for integrating stuff with python it
cannot be written in raw python it will
be too
slow um so the choices are you know
scyon which is somewhat accessible C++
which means that no researcher will ever
tou touch this rust which means only
rust people will ever touch this and
that's about it
welcome Brad things are going well the
uh the Project's looking is looking very
nice your heal is greater than
[Music]
zero we
can we can actually just make this
damage right and then you pass a
negative
value got it it's the only middle yeah
exactly and I've got to be honest I
actually love scyon it's so good like
the utility that syon when you have to
have something that has a python
interface okay which is all of AI um
scyon has such amazing support with
numpy it's nuts like do you know scon
basically gives you an entity component
system for free that is mirrored between
Python and scyon like I can make an
array from python side pass it into scon
scon can interpret that as like say a 2d
array of strs or whatever so you have
struct access to attributes but then in
Python I can do like players. health and
I get a vector with all of the health of
all the players or I can do players of
zero. health and get the health for just
one player so it has really really nice
support for
right we don't even need a function for
stun because it's literally just setting
a value
don't need a function for slow it's
literally setting a
function Channel just means that we call
AOE every step it's not that big of a
deal um self heal is just calling heal
on yourself that's
um you need to have a Teleport of some
variety so we do need a Teleport two
function cuz that's not just a move it
needs to be moved slightly
off so we're missing like teleport near
or something
and then we're missing a push I think
push and
pull do you plan on implementing an item
system so not currently I could be
swayed but training agents to buy items
is a complete pain in the ass
so much so that open AI open AI even
scripted their item build system for
open AI 5 it's really a pain to get
agents to do like these really really
sparse decision-making things that
require uh like outside knowledge I mean
people spreadsheet the heck out of their
item builds right it's really hard to
get that to come out into an RL context
we are going to have separate skills we
are going to have leveling and that sort
of thing maybe I can be convinced to do
an item system but if we do there's
going to have to there will have to be
some serious restrictions on
it you have definitely have experience
when it comes to in-game econ economies
oh yeah
um the market system in neural MMO has
been the bane of my existence let me
tell you that it's like the coolest
thing ever but it's such a pain to get
it to
work I have some more work coming out on
that actually soon where I kind of got
it to work but like it's really
hard okay let's implement this teleport
to
near there's move
to this needs to be a respawn entity not
P
right random plus you mentioned this
before but I love the idea of Open
Source bounties as a source of
Revenue or open source
software source of Revenue it's a source
of revenue for contributors to open
source software but the open source like
project still has to get some income in
order to pay those out so when puffer AI
as a company starts to get some Revenue
that's when I'm hoping to be able to do
that um but like in order for something
like that to happen basically puffer has
to get big enough that companies start
using it and want support contracts or
something like that which would then
fund bounties and such that's the goal I
don't know I've been trying to find like
nice ways to monetize stuff here um
because I don't like I don't want to
closeth Source any of this that's a
terrible idea I don't want to like do
any sh like grow Shenanigans there like
the goal is to advance science and make
money in the process not to like you
know make money and not Advance
yeah so it's definitely something I want
to do but it's going to be a little
later on in puffer when it get the
project gets a little bit bigger that's
why stuff like Star Puffer you know
promote the Twitter that stuff actually
helps me a lot because it helps
companies see puffer and start
considering using it stuff like that
right I think it will happen I'm hoping
I'm very hopeful because
like look at this level of
growth
right like this is a pretty big
repositor for RL like RL is a pretty KNE
subfield one idea I had was a sort of
internship or intention value where for
each the heroes could hold a small
string the other Heroes on both team
could see I think it would help with
coordinating yeah I've actually I
experimented with that in neural MMO as
well
um you can do
it it's really hard to tell whether
agents actually are using that in a
meaningful
way but that can be added to anything
you can add that as like you can add
that as a wrapper to any environment I
don't even have to code that into this
you can add that as a wrapper to
anything like all you'd have to do you'd
write that that's 100 lines of code that
is um at most that's you write a gym or
a petting Z wrapper in which you augment
the observation space with uh the
observation and action space with an
additional
box and then you make that box visible
to
everything that's all that that should
be
back to Dev here move
two this has got to be
entity where's move
to uh this is also we have to change the
apis on some of these
things but uh I wanted to put right
under this I wanted to put spawn
well
teleport or does it move
near entity star
entity and then entity star Target
INT and what we will
do is
um we'll put you one away I
and actually we're going to make this
return an inch as well we want it
because this is okay this returns
negative one if you fail to move if you
move it
Returns what do you do you return zero
is that the C
style I think technically you can use a
b int
but return one
one and this is going to be entity we're
not going to make this
PID so I'm just going to try to like I'm
going to try to basically move you to a
bunch of positions near the Target and
if none of them work then the the whole
thing doesn't work so if I move to
Target plus
one then return
one
so you try to move in four directions
around
it and uh
potentially yeah
perfect so you try the eight directions
around that are near the Target and if
none of them work then you return
negative 1 not zero
that's very
nice we're going to have to do with this
refactor in a little bit but uh since I
would like to put that off for a bit
we're going to just Implement some
abilities how did you learn to implement
more complex games like this it seems
like a pretty difficult thing to get
started with
I have been coding for at least 10 years
probably much more than
that 13 years 14 I don't know um this is
not actually going to be that complex of
a game if you think about it this is
like 1200 this is going to be at most
like 1,200 Total Lines of code now the
hardest part about this is actually not
any of the game stuff the hard part
about this is the RL part which took a
lot longer as for just learning how to
implement like small to midsize projects
in
general you just write a lot of code and
you get better at
spent I mean neural MMO alone was well
over $10,000 probably well over 15,000
hours on just that one
project puffer is now probably two two
to 3,000 hours in puffer lib um and of
course I've done a lot of stuff before
that so really this is if you want to
think about it that way uh this is way
smaller scope than stuff I've done
previously so this is fun cuz I don't
have to think a lot about like big
software architecture I kind of just get
to write stuff
we're going to leave these skills alone
here for now and we're going to
um C
def
oops we're just really quiet these days
that's
weird uh we're going to start here
support we're going to implement these
first uh without levels and then we'll
like modify them by levels or something
after but we're going to just do this
will be
like void
support ill
support
um book
I okay I we need to uh go implement we
need to go Implement push and pull
and the the hard thing about this is
going to be the Collision
checks
so the way I'm envisioning this in my
head is we're just going to push you in
increments of one
um so we're going to do
cdef looat
DX
Dy float DX is actually going to be
equal to
uh you're pushing the target so it's
the targetx minus player
X and then you need to get the unit
Vector for
this
so
Norm Vector to unit
dist so this will just be over
disc and then this will be over disc
okay
so we
do greater than
1.0 what we're going to do is we're
going to
to uh
player no
too
uh
okay so if you fail to
move then
break I actually would kind of prefer to
have the error code let's do in hit
wall yeah because that just feels gross
to me to to do this conditional like
this and then we'll just do
if and this should not be hit wall this
should be like success or something
so like
moved valid move I don't
know
move valid move is negative one then we
break out of
this
right decrease amount here as well and
then at the end we have to do uh the
there's a little piece maybe left
over for the move
amount so we do self. move
to uh player or no this
is this autocomplete is bad this should
all be
Target target. X plus d
okay
[Music]
and this move
to is
I can avoid having to do this if I don't
care about float amounts of movement
but I could also split the amount up
into pieces
so what I'm trying to figure out here is
uh just a nice way of doing this the way
that I'm looking at this now is like
let's say you say you're going to push
one uh 2.5 cells then you're going to
push him one push him one and then
you're going to push him five I have to
finish this at the
bottom there's several other ways I
could do this right I could like always
break your move up into five pieces so
you do a fixed number of collision
checks that seems bad
though yeah that seems bad because then
you can teleport through
things so let's do it this way let's
keep it this way I think it's I think we
had the design decent
enough plus amount times the Y so this
this is the remaining
moving now is there a way to make this
work for um
push can I just make a function pull
that has a negative
amount like is it literally as easy
as um
um
void push uh
pull self player star and then all
you're going to do is self. push
negative amount
yeah this is literally it
right okay so now we have push and pull
now we can actually start implementing
uh the skills I think so and I think
it's really easy when we uh when we have
all these like Primitives I think it's
really easy I think that's why this
is not going to be too bad to
develop
so skill support hook um self do
pull player and it's going to you're
going to be able to pull it
five was it five units
maybe six units whatever we decide this
is going to
be um next one is an AOE heal white
skill support AOE
heal and then it's going to be
in a radius of four around
maybe it's a pretty big AOE yeah and the
amount of the
heel will be
like 200 or something we're just going
to put some basic values into
stun and we don't have a stun value but
it's going to
be uh self.
attack player Target we're going to
attack for like
50 and then we're going to do uh player.
stun timer and this is an increments of
Point uh of it's five increments per
second I think is 02 seconds each so
uh 12 is a 2C stun I
believe no 10 is a 2 second stun player.
stun timer is equal to 10 and this is
not player it's Target target. stun
timer is equal to
10 literally that
simple and now if we go down to these
ones oh this code is going to be so
simple and clean when this is done this
is actually
great this is actually great
imagine if I do this in a thousand lines
miniature MOBA in a thousand
oops
burst uh or
skill
first nuke
self dot
attack or I don't
know
500 we haven't implemented attack range
and stuff yet so we'll still have to do
AOE oh actually uh this AOE heal here is
it's centered on itself so it's player
yeah and this one is centered on a
Target this one is going to have a
radius of two around a target for
200 we'll come up with we're not going
to do animations for all these things
initially but we will have some sort of
visualization method um so you can see
when when skills are being
played that will definitely be a
thing we got to add Mana cost and other
things as well but this is you know this
is good uh
um
o I didn't include a stun ability in an
AOE did I
well we'll just leave this a
Todo add
no done to
AOE it's done
two Z St
equals okay so that one we didn't quite
cover
yet let's cover um the Juggernaut thing
which is the
tank void skill
tank are you using an engine for making
the game or something
custom uh the logic for it is just in
scon so there's no engine uh there's no
engine whatsoever in fact this is the
entire source code for this thing and uh
I don't know if you've seen it on X but
there are some gifts posted on X from
yesterday um and the rendering is done
in rib if you haven't seen RB it is
awesome it's super
lightweight I love this thing so
much
um it just gives you really lowle
Primitives for like drawing shapes and
drawing textures and drawing text and
stuff like that uh there's like a basic
camera but it's very very low level like
people make very basic stuff in it but
actually you can make stuff look pretty
good as
well okay skill tank uh we're going to
do this is
the AOE
Dot and we have we have to add Mana cost
here how's the game currently look I can
show the gift because I'm in the middle
of building it so I can't run it while
I'm in the middle of uh you know edits
but this is day four of
building and this was a cool gift hold
creeps they go around the tower they
fight the other creep creeps that's a
skill I just nuked the other
creeps um this is them fighting the
towers which were under balanced at the
time and then gets killed by these you
know these uh random these randoms
here this is navigate this is me playing
this is navigation by Mouse and then
you'll see I will stop a push right here
of
creeps so very basic but um this is day
four total of develop
so making good progress It's already
kind of
fun it's also all open source so if you
want to actually see the code it's in
this random uh this random any config
branch of puffer lib give puffer a star
on your way and it helps me a
lot there you go rib is awesome if I had
to like if I'm choosing like top
libraries I've ever seen uh for like any
purpose RB is definitely way up there
Raab is god
so we got to add Mana CLA for this to
make
sense but this is an AOE around the
player that has
like a smallish radius and does like
light damage
doesn't have a
heal this is a self
heal was there a self-d heal function I
think there
250 you know technically I don't even
need to have these things in function
and I might take them out of functions
at some point I might just put them in
line in the main Loop
this is the first one that has a
slow it also has a push self back which
I didn't think about but we might be
able to do that with the existing
so oh yeah we can totally do this cuz
it's it's a
push and you're pushing the player away
from the Target right
and then we do a
slow so it's going to be
Target move timer is going to
be uh a let's make it a 3 second slow so
15 move
modifier is going to be 0
point uh 30% slow Maybe
100 you inflict uh maybe a shorter slow
a more mild
slow I don't
know we might just take some of these
values from actual DOTA characters or
League characters at some point so I
don't have to balance it myself but I'm
sure that it's not going to be one to
one cuz like the engine is different and
like all the stats are different right
AOE no biggie this was just a clear tool
for creeps I
minions uh so we have to add like a
Target
category so too restrict to
minions player Target big
AOE for like a lot of
interesting I don't think the minions
have this much health
so what if I made it so that
um you can Target it on this would be a
cool trick you can Target it on minions
but then it can affect other
players right so like
minions splashes to
players that's
okay TP
burst so now we get the teleport skill
near return and then we do an
attack big big damage
attack and then the last one is a move
Speed
or uh
player what is it that move mod it move
mod what is
it
1.5 player. move
skills yeah so that's like a very basic
first pass at all the
skills um we need to
do a little bit of API refactor because
we changed everything from using this
complicated PID system to just using
some
pointers we need to think about uh edge
cases and limitations here because there
were a couple skills I couldn't fully
Implement like this and then we need to
add all of these um these move effects
right now they don't actually do
anything um the way it works is
instantaneous effects are applied by the
skill to the Target immediately but
things that like uh things that linger
over time like a slow that slow has to
be
applied um uh that slow has to be like
updated and applied every step so that
goes in the main
Loop The View count has gone up a whole
bunch so um welcome
everybody all this is open source right
here in puffer lib puffer a/p puffer lib
U it's in the any config Branch right
now right here merging it to Dev soon if
you want to help out the project please
just give it a star helps me out a whole
ton and all this is also an
X the goal for this game is to have it
running at a minimum of uh 1 million 1
million player steps per second so since
they're 10 players it has to run at
essentially like
um it has to run at essentially like 100
th000 FPS or whatever without rendering
and that's so that it can get enough
data to feed the learning
algorithm the rendering doesn't have to
be particularly fast just has to be
playable
speed let's go start on this little
refactor
fine spawn methods are
fine reset method is
fine move
to this needs to be swapped from PID to
else this is player.
PID and this is player.
PID we just wrote move near so it's
fine we need to modify a kill to take
already creep path can be modified as
well to take entity star creep
creep.
pit and then this is
re creep
targeting is also
here entity
star uh this is Target right no this is
entity star creep okay
creep uh get entity Target pit is
fine this attack is
now going to be
creep Target
Two pathing
takes uh the creep as
index the index is
fine all we have to do is give this this
creep instead of creep up p and this is
actually much more efficient as
well because we're avoiding several
calls to get entity by just passing
around the pointers instead of the pits
so in fact this is cleaner and it's also
faster very marginally but it is
faster spawn creep
wave uh these variables should be CDE
fine this function is otherwise
correct respawn takes an
entity this function looks
correct attack takes a
player this also looks
correct we just wrote all this code so
this code should be fine at least it
should be
updated um these skill attacks and stuff
we're going to get rid of these in a
moment anyways but in the meantime we
can do entity star
player entity star
Target and then this AOE attack takes
player Target
200 heel is going to also take entity
star player does not need a Target
and then the main thing that we have to
update
is uh the main thing that we have to
update is this step function
here because this step function assumes
a bunch of
nice uh this takes a uh this makes a lot
of a assumptions about
PID
creep so what we're going to do is we're
going to get the creep
here we make an entity star creep creep
is get entity and then we pass this to
the
AI and if creep. pit is ne1 we can
simply exit out meaning that we don't
need to do any other pit checks anywhere
else so let's go check for
that yeah we don't need this check
here since we put it in line here which
is I think
cleaner it's cleaner to catch it before
the function call
I don't like this particular little bit
of
logic
um
so why don't we do why don't we make a
get creep
function which is going to just do the
indexing Force which is idx plus num
agents plus num
Towers that's a little bit nicer I don't
like having this logic in line so now we
can just
do uh this is now
idx in range of b. num oops nope num
creeps now we get this is no longer get
entity this is get creep of
index yes and if the pit is negative one
then you we simply ignore it
we've got this discretization
here don't particularly like this being
maybe okay
so this is
the reap AI block is right here
now we have the
[Music]
tower Tower AI is
here we get the
tower
um I think we kill the towers when their
health is less than zero don't we I
think we can simplify
this yeah we do we kill the tower
meaning that their PID should be
negative one right
yes entity pit is negative one so we
don't need to do this janky check
against
Health we can simply check this the way
we check every other entity in the game
which is if the PID is ne1 we continue
now this these two blocks look pretty
much identical which is very
nice uh we don't need to Define this
here we can just this can
yeah I kind of like this a little better
so
now uh is this an
AOE this is an AOE isn't
it we wanted to prevent the towers from
hitting each other but they're not going
to hit each other because they're on the
same team anyways
right so I think that this is actually
literally we replace this entire block
with self.
AOE centered on
itself
right radius of tower vision and then
Tower damage and we delete this entire
block that's
clean that's very
clean I like that a
now we have a PID
here we get the player let's see if we
can do anything
similar player logic is a little bit
more
complicated
um we'll be cheeky and we'll put player
I which actually is player AI because
it's
now this player
logic that was going to be
cheeky uh let's fix the API stuff first
and then we'll go modify all of the
various status effects in the game
because the the players need the status
effects actually the creeps need status
effects too don't
that we'll probably just make an update
status function that can Target any
entity type that's what we'll
do so player is going to be get entity
of
PID we get Y and X
because we're getting it
from um player
observation
here maybe this is
okay we're getting the targets
pit do we even need the target pit I
think we get rid of this and we just do
skill
attack player and Target right that's
the new API and that's
easier player heals
player Target five okay that's actually
way easier than I thought it would
be and then we have this discretization
Shenanigans
again you know why don't we do this all
in one spot
right why make it
hard let's just put this up
here if discretise we do velocity Cals
up here we do velocity Cals up here
that's way nicer right
and the destination and the move gets
done at the
end so now we simply have this nice
block of logic where we update
Mana we get the actions from the
player we get the selected Target and we
attack heal or whatever we're going to
do that's very
we need to make an update status
function because it's going to have to
be called by both the players uh the
players and the creeps so let's make an
update
defining we ended up defining a stun
timer and a move timer only
right okay okay so we just update the
timers anything else we have to
do that was actually a lot simpler than
I thought now we do have to update in a
few other places there are a couple
other small
things let's do self. update status of
player and then the creep also has to
get the status
updated self update status and it's got
to be right here before we
know uh when we know it's valid
okay so the main thing is we have to
change uh in
movement movement is the main thing that
gets modified
right I suppose uh attack also gets
modified because if you try to attack
and your stuned nothing happens
right is that where I want to add the
logic I mean there are all sorts of
skills that players
have
so I think that right
here we just do if self or if player.
stun timers greater than zero
continue movement will be handled by the
move timer
I like handling it here
actually and then we handle right
here before or after the status
update not particularly important where
it wears off right
here before the status
update uh Mana should definitely regen
even if you're stunned
though that's
nice yeah so before the status
update that's much
better where do I use player
.x I only actually use player dox once
so I can put player player doy and
player dox here
destination the destination the logic
doesn't take into account slows at the
moment
the update status function actually
should reset
um oops I misspelled
assassin the uh the move timers actually
need to be a little bit
different if the move timer is zero
then
entity move modifier needs to be
1.0
right that
way I do self. move
modif
modifier I like getting rid of these um
these
spaces so this this gives you the
ability to slow down players what about
creeps how does creep pathing
path so we have a function that we wrote
that paths towards a Target
do uh first of all it's not self. aent
speed now it's creep. agentp speed we
gave it as a
property no we
didn't we haven't done that yet
we do have
creep that move modifier
right
there now they can be subjected to move
modifiers I think that's more efficient
it requires us to change it in two
places but it would be more efficient
than the alternative which would require
us to do an expensive Vector
normalization operation every time
which I'd like to avoid doing those if I
can uh currently they're only required
for push and pull actions which are very
rare
so I think that the approach now is
going to be to
debug whatever we assuredly broke
here and
then we're going to start integrating
the
skills the skills that we
wrote with the various
players and then after
that
um we will iterate on the
skills to make them more reasonable and
we'll add some graphics to them as well
that seems like a good
idea we still
have well I've been doing this for two
hours we've got another five hours of
most of these look really
easy uh entity star Target we don't need
that
hey guys what has been implemented so
far I will show
you this is day four
oops this is what we had at the end of
the day
yesterday I'm the red puffer in here
here these are my
minions they just pass Tower I just used
a skill to Nuke all the minions minions
took out a
tower the towers were not balc so the
towers were too weak at the time and
then the minion dies because minions
feed and we go back there we will be
just in time to prevent a push from the
enemy
minions same three lanes it's actually
it's uh it's based on the DOTA map not
the league map we just haven't added all
the additional um hallways and things in
but yeah it's same three lanes in fact I
can give you the high level of
it here maybe this will be cooler this
is really uh not this
one so you can see the
Minions Minions fighting
far this is all on my GitHub as
well um it's in here on the uh the
any it's in the any config branch of
puffer lib give puffer lib a star on
your way in helps me out a bunch
and what we've been working on today is
we've been working on
implementing um 15 skills so we're going
to have five different Heroes they will
each have three skills so 15 total
skills it will be a mirror match a
5v5 and uh I want to get that working
today maybe not with like good
animations but at least with some sort
of
visualization of uh the skills and what
they're doing the skills were designed
on stream with viewers uh last night so
we went back and forth on a bunch of
different skills for different agent or
different
characters some were modeled off of
League characters some were modeled off
of DOTA characters some were a mix of
the two and uh I just did an initial
implementation of all these of all the
skills right
here um they're not all that complicated
like if you think about it most skills
it's like some combination of damage
single Target or AOE
move or stun maybe a push or a pull so a
lot of them are very
easy and now we're going to get that to
work of course I just did a huge
refactor so it's going to take a little
bit
to get it all running
correctly but not that bad
new Watcher here with no connection to
coding but huge love for DOTA have you
thought about posting this project on
the DOTA Reddit You' get a ton of Love
since open AI did the same thing uh yeah
this is a brand new project I've only
been working on this for uh for 3 days
so once it looks more like uh like Dota
or once it looks more like an actual
game then yeah I could definitely post
some stuff it would be cool um the fun
thing about the the DOTA story so that
was an inspiration for a lot of my work
know I did my PhD for the last five
years just got out just got finished
with it um and a lot the inspiration for
a lot of my work was open ai5 I was
about 15 feet away from those guys when
they were working on it and it was the
coolest darn project I've ever seen and
also the most talented team I've ever
seen that team was cracked beyond belief
so and they actually they found stuff in
reinforcement learning that like the
majority of Academia hasn't caught up to
even today even though they published it
it's
crazy the sad thing was like how slow
the environment was right like it was so
slow to run it you needed such large
scale compute so um this is not going to
be a fulls scale mooba obviously but
it'll be you know the bare bones of a
MOA and you're going to be able to train
this thing on a one in one day on one
GPU to do something interesting I can
guarantee that uh because this is going
to run at a million frames per second so
yeah and it's not going to take that
long to build either I'm intending this
to be like a one to two we project to
get something working and then we'll see
how long we spend fiddling with it and
tuning it after that
could you go over the RL algorithm
you're using for the agents at some
point yeah it's the same as that they
were using in um in open A5 it's just po
proximal policy
optimization um reinforcement learning
algorithms have basically been stagnant
since 2017 18 whenever it was published
P's kind of just solved everything um
and DotA was solved with uh many people
aren't aware of this but the open ai5
model was a on layer lstm really fancy
encoder and decoder but like it was a
one layer lstm whole model had like 150
million parameters so
yeah not sure if you thought about
monetizing this but what about selling
the finished version of this to pro team
so they could train nowadays they only
train against other teams so they can't
practice all their strategies this is
not going to be close enough to a uh a
full scale MMO for that and like the
amount of time I'd have to invest to do
that versus the amount of money I could
potentially make is just straight up not
worth it um my focus now is 100% on
fixing the whole reinforcement learning
ecosystem and making RL sane and
consistent and any money I'm going to
make is going to come from uh from
companies that need that not so much
spin-off
applications also this is all open
source
what are you thinking for the
architecture it's going to be very basic
we're going to need to have well not
that basic um we're going no not a
Transformer Transformer is too heavy you
didn't even need a transformer for full
scale DOTA uh we want this thing to
train at hundreds of thousands of steps
per
second it's going to be likely a very
small convet for uh the obstacle map
like the 2D map data and then there's
going to be some sort of attentional
thing maybe like a multi-head attention
block but not a full Transformer over
the entity data which is like the nearby
players or
creeps and then for the decode there's
going to be an lstm and then for the
decoder um there's one section of it
that is very basic that just has linear
layers for decoding actions and then
there's one section that's kind of
entity specific where you have to pick a
nearby Target to attack um but neither
of them are too complicated you're also
able to run this with discrete or
continuous actions so uh your movement
can be discret or continuous so there'll
be Integrations for that as
well but I am confident that we can get
this thing training at the very least
several hundred thousand steps per
second and then simulating it like at
least a million steps per second per CPU
core X1 y1 X2
Y2 so uh
Target X target.
Y player. X player.
Y yeah puffer all about like puffer
ultra high performance
RL you can make things very very fast
with
puffer for reference we
did um obviously this is a simpler
environment even though the tech is the
same but like this thing this is snake
with 4096 snakes uh the simulation for
this runs uh 14 million snake steps per
second on one CPU core and this trains
at a million steps per second at least
on one GPU
with just like a little convet plus
lstm as I mentioned before I've got very
little to no knowledge about coding
could you explain simply how open AI
managed to use a code about playing DOTA
to create the chat bot well it wasn't a
chat bot oh I see what you mean to
create it like how does one apply the
same
idea yeah so
um AI used to be like a bunch of
different subfields where you needed
really different knowledge um like to
work in natural language processing
versus RL versus Vision but it's gotten
closer and closer together over the last
several years so now it's basically like
there are a set of common neuronet
architectures that you can kind of just
throw at anything and they will work the
infrastructure is different and there's
some different considerations but pretty
much any that has been working in any
area of machine learning for several
years can move to any other area of
machine learning within a couple of
months
so yeah it's mainly just that like the
architectures the optimizers the data
practices like everything ends up
looking very similar it's like there
it's the way that you just chug make a
data a model chug tons of data looks
very similar regardless of what the data
is you also used INB carbs for that
right yes uh imbue carbs is amazing I
posted on that that today um it's it's
really a great algorithm it's going to
change RL at this point you got to put
that snake animation on the website at
some point when I get bored enough I
might dip my toes into a little bit of
webd uh I have zero experience
whatsoever with web development and I
really don't want to have to try to like
rewrite the environment in JavaScript if
I can avoid it um not to mention you
have to run the neuron networks in order
to you know make the snakes control them
like to control the snakes so I don't
know if some web dev actually has if
somebody with good web dev experience
can tell me like a good simple way of
doing this that's not going to drive me
crazy then
absolutely um but yeah it's tough oh
just the gift yeah yeah yeah I I'm going
to put gifts on the website there going
to be lots of gifts on the website I'm
going to do a big like environment and
simulation update we'll have lots of
nice graphics online that's not problem
uh the gift is on Twitter lots of things
have been on Twitter um people really
like the snake project this my uh my own
Twitter shot up like 1,200 followers
just from the snake project so that was
cool
yeah the snake environment is also it's
playable and it's pretty fun
now maybe it works in this
version maybe I broke it I don't know
yeah okay I broke the environment in the
latest uh Branch I'll fix that before I
merge
it it still works in the dev Branch I
believe
bugs
what did this not recompile correctly
bugs expected five it takes radius and
damage so radius for this is uh
near assassinate
TP and then we have 720
player
nice so let's see if we can get this
thing running
again um with the
refactors we only added 120 lines of
code with all the skill system and it
can actually made a fair bit shorter
so that's not bad at all
Segal
o what are you
making uh we're making
this it's a miniature MOBA for
reinforcement learning so this is going
to be uh strip down MOBA for the purpose
of training AI to play
it and doing research on that it's going
to run super fast it's going to have all
all of the basic elements essentially of
am
MOA and it's going to be a relatively
short and easy to follow
project this is day four of coding this
thing this is from uh last night this
little demo today we're adding uh five
different hero types with different
abilities and hopefully we can get a
little bit more than that as done as
well today
MOA got we we've got three lanes we've
got creep
waves we've got
Towers creeps can destroy
Towers towers are a little undertuned at
the
moment
yeah that's what we're
building any
possibility that learned agents in this
setting can be transferred to more
complex
mobus uh not directly transferred but
the techniques uh the techniques and the
decisions can be transferred so for
instance I would presume that uh if you
were able to train like let's say if
open a had built some if open AI had
built something like this uh early
on it would have been substantially
easier to do a bunch of experiments to
see what works and what doesn't here
really really fast and then it would you
know save a lot of the heavier and more
difficult to do experiments on the full
scale
environment so that's the type of thing
it's meant for like rapid prototyping
and
research you're not going to be able to
transfer the policies directly you will
be able to transfer the methods and the
insights and that's a lot of what puffer
is about for
for my RL project last quarter my friend
and I traded making an evolution
simulator on top of madona Madrona I
assume we got like 150 case training
steps per
second that's actually very oh wait you
got 150k train with RL that's actually
very
uh I'd actually be very surprised if you
got that with like the crappy
vectorization methods that are available
without
puffer it's you pretty hard to get that
without having good
vectorization um but yeah with puffer
any simple environment you can get up to
millions of steps per second
simulation and simple environments you
can get like a million steps per second
train relatively complicated
environments can still get hundreds of
thousands provided the Sim is fast
I nothing should be able to be seg
falting
I'm going to be interested to see what's
actually seg
puling I guess technically the getter
functions could be seg
pting okay it's not seg folting on
respawn
God I wish we had better be better
debugging tools for
this um
one of my favorite tricks for
multi-agent by the way
um it's actually very it's substantially
easier to
simulate uh one environment with 2048
agents fast than it is to simulate 20 48
environments with one agent fast um at
least a little bit easier so multi-agent
is kind of nice okay so it is seg
folting maybe on the creep AI let's
figure out
okay so it's seg folting on the creep AI
somewhere
can you explain the decision making
for making the multiple agents
work is it one network with batched
inputs yes each output corresponding to
an agent yes the network is
independently applied to each agent but
it is shared weights it's one network so
that means that you're independently
controlling the agents but all the data
that you're getting from all of the
agents is being used to train the same
network so it's very nice for
acceleration
creep
spawn apparently update status is
failing so I'm assuming that I wrote a
parameter that doesn't
exist stun timer move timer move
modifier is that what I called it move
uh PID might not be negative one I could
just be out of bounds here already right
so when I do that
PID let me say get creep
idx num
creeps right and
then get
creep
entities I agents plus numb Towers plus
idx I'm pretty sure that's
it's possible that it's just getting a
bad memory
PID update status this exists
right yeah
is I'm assuming this is the compiler not
catching something it should totally be
variables yeah I didn't initialize these
stupid variables did I move timer move
modifier yep
okay I did I did initialize them I
initialized
them right there move mod movees
huh wait wait wait it's seg
fting before we get
there
oh you
dummy absolute dummy
it's obnoxious very obnoxious makes me
rethink my
uh practice of doing all the allocations
at the top of the function
actually that's really weird because I
thought you'd get an uninitialized
check
move so this is player
I guess
um I guess the uninitialized check
doesn't apply to strs so if you
initialize a struct or if you forget to
initialize a struct it won't tell you if
you forget to initialize like
um maybe a python type it'll tell you I
don't know that's weird because I have
initialized check
on okay uh I have it running on the
other monitor we'll do demo time we'll
play it a little bit to see um I'll just
take these prints out and then we'll
play it a little bit to see if it's the
same as before uh probably there going
to be some bugs and crashes things to
you know to get rid
heal seems to work skills seem to
work so for the folks that were asking
what the game looks like this is what
the game looks
like you can move slow you can move
fast just depends on where your cursor
is direct the puffers
maybe we can stop a wave from pushing
somewhere
here where's the
wave they come I think once a
minute oh yeah got three
lanes lanes feel a little bit narrow
delete
[Music]
works I need to add a I need to add AIP
method to this
why did you choose puffer
fish it's puffer lib this is our
mascot and
Logo you got to feed the
puffer the puffer subsists entirely on a
diet of reinforcement learning
environments and infrastructure sure
okay Escape now kills the uh the program
so that's
good now we can start integrating skills
I think and we start integrating the
skills I'm going to think about how to
do that for a moment I'm going to use
the restro I'll be back in a minute or
two and uh we will turn this into an
actual mobile with like five different
class cles which will be cool I don't
know if we're going to do scripted AI
for them or not we might do scripted AI
for them it would probably help we'll
see we are definitely going to make them
playable though so I'll be right
Twitter is really quiet today I don't
know what's
up is this uh
something
oh oh this is
carolus he's cool
let's start on implementations
here let's um whoops before we break
anything let's Commit This so you guys
can have
it are you interested in training a
Minecraft Agent no the game is way too
slow Minecraft is it would it would be a
somewhat interesting domain but the game
just runs way too
slow like a thousand times too
not bad so this whole refactor plus the
initial skills was 111 Total
Lines not bad at all so that's now
committed up you guys can play with it
if you
want if the stream gets big enough maybe
I'll get bug fix PRS in real time that
would be
cool but uh for now I have to fix my own
bugs which is only
let me think how I want to implement
this well first of
all I think they need an extra button
right cuz they I gave them three skills
not
two so let's start by giving them an
extra
button this is a two this is a
six and
qw this is skill Q This is skill
W skill
fine now how do I want to select the
skills on this side of
um do I want to just write it all
out it's kind of a lot isn't
this is going to be
use
q
e so we got q w and
e
um I should also make this like nine so
they stop spamming skills so
maybe we'll see about
that probably we're going to have
specific actions that are discreet and
specific actions that are continuous but
for the time
being use
Q do if um player.
PID
five then we use the uh the first
skill which I'm going to forget all the
names of these I'm
sure
um was it support
hook let's just copy the first few of
these so we have them as
reference do
skill
support
hook player
Target and
then
if this is kind of gross logic we'll
figure this out later
E I kind of want to flip
this yeah let's flip this let's do it
like this instead that's slightly better
still disgusting but slightly better if
use
w z s. skill support
stun okay
LF player.
PID
six if use
Q oh it's is it is it just going to
autocomplete like semi-
reasonably
oh uh thank you super
Maven thank you a
lot that's actually really
nice now uh this this El has to go on
all of them actually that's the one
slightly gross thing not too bad
though
cool and then we get rid of these cuz
they're already
find
so we're supposed to have our character
is zero so we're supposed to have a hook
an AOE heal and a
stun I'm sure that we'll have some bugs
with this
um at least in the game play if not in
the
okay I think technically can you stun
Towers the way it's
written not
sure don't think
so operand could Okay cool so we have
our first shape error
here numpy do clip right I forgot to
update
um distance is the L2
distance let's just
let's see where it's trying to teleport
me and I'm going to turn the AC down one
sec
um I don't know why it's targeting
itself but it should uh that's probably
what was
happening because then you would be
dividing by zero which would give you
Nan
H wait Target
doy
what's wrong with this there should be a
pretty substantial border around the map
that prevents it from going out of
bounds
here I see
so if amount
we're going to say if there's you have
to be still have a little bit left to
move so what was happening is I was
calling it with an integer so then I was
moving it uh basically to its same
position though thinking about
that I don't know if that would make it
screw up or not
DX where was my uh actually where was
the the airor
message
DX
wait what
what valid
move move two
something screwy with
that let's fix that
first this is to fix the um the hook
skill like the Pudge or thresh hook
skill as well as uh some Retreat skills
and other
things it seems we just did some bad
division
somewhere okay so let me see if these
look weird
distance
three
DX
Dy
so this is a self
teleport right this is teleporting onto
itself
somehow
so I don't know how that's
happening but
somehow is it possible there's a
something on the same
position that should not be possible
but we'll just do
later okay so this is now more
reasonable data
right let's take a look at some of these
whoops um
so we get
like Target DX
Dy this DX and Dy is
right DX and
Dy they're supposed to be normalized
oh it looks like um it's the last call
where it gets out of hand which is this
one so
Target target. y plus amount times
Dy and amount
dot
DX but I've
said oh it's trying to move it all at
once
return so what's happening is if it was
hitting a wall it was trying to teleport
at the remaining
distance silly little
bug if we run this
now we should get something more
reasonable
and now we can see that all of the
Deltas
here uh these are correctly they look
like they're normed to one which is what
we
want yeah I believe these are all Norm
to about
one okay so
now we have very simple push and pull
code we're going to rebuild this and
we're going to see if we can actually
run this thing for long enough to try
out some skills
we're going to start with the AOE
hook which is
you uh this does not appear to be
triggering but it's hard to
tell well it's not consuming my Mana at
the very least I think we forgot to add
mana mana consumption
to
these let's go do
that if uh player.
Mana
return then I'm just going to do player.
Mana we're just going to make it or uh
was
it we're just going to do this for now
just as a test
Okay
so this Q is not
triggering it's not triggering the
ability did I remember to
rebuild yes I
did so skill support
hook use
Q use Q this should be
correct Q
oops
build let's see why this skill is not
being
doesn't seem like I can use
it I think it's the other puffer that's
using the
skill doesn't seem like I'm capable of
using
it so is it just processing my uh my
attacks
wrong use Q
where's this
clip so step is going to be
clip from 0 to
one and Human
Action self. Human Action is client.
render
which is returned right
and if ax and a y is
none then action is
none otherwise action
is a YX attack qwe
which looks
correct so let's see if it's correct
going into the environment which is
right
here
human oops well that's
fine let's see if the action is correct
going into the environment
okay
so here we have the environment if I'm
holding
is my e
works my w does not
work and my Q doesn't work but my e does
well this is a for some reason it's
interpreting this as a push
right why is it every time that I I hit
this
thing oh it's like interpreting my
attackes a push or
something because every time I get the
cursor on it it pushes it
yeah so are the keys messed
up let's
see q w e skill Q skill W skill e
oops we can see it actually does take my
mana and if I oops can I get the puffer
out of my way
heal I can't hook a pupper which is
obnoxious can't hook
this guy's like blinking after me isn't
he yeah the thing is that's teleporting
all over the place is using a
blink hey
Quinn welcome
I don't know what my w is doing but it's
like murking
stuff Let's uh get rid of these prints
and figure out what the heck is going on
right possibly we just have some bugs in
the implementations
okay q w e all the skills are getting
triggered uh let's go take some damage
because this well not that much damage
hello
puffers uh maybe not that much damage
okay so I pressed W and they all
died so that's not what we wanted to
happen
and then
e e is supposed to be a stun that's a
little harder to
test Q we can see our Mana
decrease let's figure out what's wrong
with our heal so AOE player player
4200 well very simply that's uh 200
damage it should be negative 200 right
heal we also probably are going to want
to
start drawing these somehow
well that did not
help I liter I said I said negative -200
and I killed all my own puffers
somehow and also apparently I'm dead but
not dead maybe just one
if damage is greater than zero you
attack
oh this needs to be negative damage
that's
why okay very small little
bugs small little
bugs so now we should be able to
basically because we haven't tuned this
yet and we haven't made it cost any Mana
we should be able to um
make these infinitely strong puffers
which is
fun
so you will not kill my
puffers my puffers will be fully healed
forever you see I'm keeping the puffers
fully healed
they heal fully every time I press it do
not kill the
puffers the infinite Mana healing puffer
has
arrived uh what else do I have I have
stun yeah but they kill they kill the
puffers very quickly if I don't come to
help um
and they I think they like one hit my
team or
something what else do I have I have a
Q it's hard to test the other ones this
one definitely works
I think they're healing as well I mean
technically all the puffers are just
spamming random skills right now so
that's why like some of these are
teleporting around like because there's
a Teleport
skill how do I tell if the stun is
working doesn't appear to
be
works I'm kind of wondering
like because it's not doing animations
right I could
make I could just make a lot more of the
skills be channeled
like if I made the push skill for
instance be channeled you'd actually be
able to see what's going
right hm
a lot of stuff to test
here well I can just swap in skills
right here
do carry
AOE carry I want to see this Retreat
slow let's put this on my
to this is supposed to make you knock
like knock you back from the opponent
oh yeah look it
works it targets anything now and it's
really Jank
right but it totally
works so if we just smooth out the
controls just a little bit so let's make
it here let's make the uh Retreat slow
let's make it be
like 0.2 or
something let's see if that makes it
like animate for us
this uh it's because I'm moving at the
same time that it doesn't look like it's
a ton of movement but it's definitely
pushing me
away this is only at movement speed
though
right maybe this will look
good five times that
speed I'm just trying to get a sense of
what these things look like and then we
can find two in the
skills okay
so boom let's
see so like you're going towards a
Target and then
boom yeah that looks good right
obviously the targeting is kind of Jank
cuz it's hard to like keep your cursor
on it so I'll have to fix the targeting
but that looks good you push yourself
away right and you can push from
whatever
nice okay so this if this works this
means that push and pull skills will
work
identically um anything with like
movement manipulation will
work let's
do uh I think assassinate TP damage is
kind of
cool let's
do s. skill
assassinate uh
TP TP damage and then instead of the AOE
heal let's give it a assassin move
buff uh I'll keep the heal actually
that's useful for
testing we'll set this up and let's see
if this feels
reasonable we could get little icons
designed for the
puffers like class icons we could also
get them uh
animated I have animation 3D file I just
don't have 2D
so I don't know where assassinate thinks
it's taking me but apparently it takes
you somewhere if
um if you press it when there's no
target so we'll have to resolve that
does not seem to kill the
puffers it does definitely jump you
around a bunch and what's the other one
I wanted a move buff oh yeah look at
this move
buff
right does this
work oh yeah
see yeah you can really see it if you
slow
double
speed and what's wrong with the
one AOE player
Target it's attack player Target
600 seems like that should work
okay so we have puffer speed oh yeah
that's a move buff
right now we've got the AOE heals on
them we're not murking them with uh we
should be like murking them with
theis but doesn't seem to work work that
way move speed buff is
weird we're have to make some better
controls I think for
uh for the human
works yeah why does this freaking TP
assassinate not work
near move
to Target doy plus
1.0 would some bottom line console
message be
useful
um logs of some sort would be useful
yes they're just somewhat annoying to
get back from
python there's definitely going to be
more visualization and stuff than we
have now I'm kind of just fiddling with
it to get a sense for like what works
and what
doesn't like somehow in here this is not
teleporting correctly I
return
one logic is pretty clean here I think
it's
so if it's teleporting it should
actually give
me assassin TP damage
so somebody's getting the Assassin TP
damage it's just not
me not getting the Assassin damage here
right
oop
okay player. PID is
zero let me try this way see if it
thinks I'm getting the assassinate TP
damage
cuz right now it looks like the other
puffer is getting it but I'm not
so interesting it thinks I'm getting the
assassinate TP damage but nothing is
taking any
damage
um the only thing I can do is lure them
to this
Tower the tower kill
them okay
definitely not doing the damage it says
I'm getting the damage but I'm not
getting it so is it applying it to the
wrong
it target. health is greater than
zero turn
right could this be 20 yeah this could
feasibly be 20 right
not attacking it am I why am I not
attacking
it these
puffers are attacking
right can't even see what's going on now
these puffers are attacking
it can I hit
debugging I'm G have to do this one
immediately maybe I'll uncover it while
fixing the other ones
so a lot of the difficulty here is just
me not having a a cool
down on button
presses means like when you press a
button it just spams it right
I can fix that easily enough though
right
I could also Implement a simple Global
cool down very easily
right instead of having to design around
this oh wait I don't even have to
implement a global cool down
think I could pretty Implement easily
Implement cooldowns
right
yeah very
easily now that I'm thinking about
Q is
it
q q
go now we add update
cooldowns now we can actually make
abilities cost mana and have cool Downs
not spam when you hold the button
let's go back to
um our original skills Maybe
which was
what the
hook those are still hard to
test I know what's going to make this
easier we need to just fix the
targeting uh for like the mouse the
human Mouse targeting
what we've got to do is we've just got
to
um we've got to like fix the controls a
little
bit so what my idea here is
um instead of having to like have your
cursor over the enemy
exactly um we're just going to make it
so that when you use a skill and you
have your cursor positioned it'll just
apply it to the
nearest uh the nearest Target which
makes sense
right
so to do that we'll
do uh
nearest it
none uh
four
range minus
3 +
4 get
1 this
to
Target let's do
nearest or
shortest
disc okay and we'll
do if shortest dist is
none then we do shortest dist and
then the
Target nearest Target is
Target
right nearest Target is
none Target PID
anything I think we broke our attacks
right
nice speed boost
oh I would like to know why uh we get
this teleport
thing right we can
actually avoid the these
guys we can aggro them like this
right it's kind of cool how we can move
them
around uh I really would like to know
how yeah it's really weird how
happening yeah it's uh the the
observations are not getting cleared out
I think
CU it shouldn't just be blinking all
over the
I'd like to know why it is that this
attack is not working this is like not
seeming to go
off though it could just be that they're
always like healing themselves The
Towers aren't healing themselves though
right
that we also wait we need to just put
the player
how did you code this stun does it apply
a stun state to the Target yes I don't
know if it's currently working
though this heal
works and I can lure these I can lure
them next to the tower right
I have the move boost
works is this taking
damage doesn't look to me like the tower
is taking any
damage is very weird because it says
attack right
attack but I don't actually see it
registering the
attack possibly it's attacking the wrong
thing we've had this happen before right
little bit of detail on the stun State
um players have a stun
counter and a stun just sets the stun
counter to some number of ticks and then
when players go to do anything you check
the stun counter and uh if the stun
counter is not zero you decrease it but
then the player can't do anything
oops attacking
zero so zero is my own
PID right now it's is attacking ne1
which means it's not attacking
anything so it actually looks like I'm
inflicting damage on negative one which
is very
bad so I think that this actually does
need a check for a
PID if target. PID
one
return definitely this needs
a a uh Target and then this one also we
can just put one
on um but now why is it negative one is
the
question there should be something
better than
it's a cool way to do it how many other
states does it check when a player tries
to make a movement other than
stun is that how you do all the status
yeah that's this is how you do all the
status effects so they're not that many
for this it's really just there's a
movement status effect like a move speed
slow or move boost that's got a timer
and then stuns got a timer those are the
only two timers I have at the moment oh
they're also their cool Downs so coold
Downs are also on that timer though I
haven't added I haven't like made
anything have a long cooldown yet okay
so now we can see
that um we're no longer doing damage to
an entity that doesn't exist which is
we can see here that it still says
attacking negative one which is very
weird what about if I put the cursor up
here
no very weird that it says attacking
negative
one so it's possible it's just something
in my
targeting because everybody else seems
to be just
fine does my did my heal stop working
no I'm not taking damage randomly so I'm
going to assume it's something in the
targeting let me see if this looks
right I tried to do something nice
here
um
so says Mouse
y Mouse
X which is
raw Mouse is this is where the mouse is
inside of the
game so you go three tiles in either
direction of the
mouse check the target
and then you get the entity of that
Target
pit compute the
distance and then you get the the
nearest
now you probably don't want to selfcast
selfcast just can be done automatically
so we
do if Target pit is zero you also do a
continue let's see if that
[Music]
see okay
thing attacking zero attacking
20 well that's really odd wait
now no even when I have it here it says
attacking 20 which
is know weird that it says that but it's
still not losing
Health move boost is really fun
bizarre maybe let's just start tuning
this I don't know and will something
will come to me
anymore uh support Hook is going to
be a channeled
skill it's going to
[Music]
consume
say 10 man per
cell it has to be channeled for the
animation to work
cell so what we're going to
do
manaal
15 no cool down
unit
next we've got the AOE
heal which heals
200 this is
fine we've got a two seconds
done we're going to make it a oops not
that strong
this going to be a 3 second stun that
does light
damage
um now when we
do when we do these attacks
here I think that the skills themselves
need to check for a
Target so if
return if player. Mana is less
than oh this is going to be
a say 60 Mana
skill
turn and we're to
attack layer. Mana is going to be minus
15 player.
qtimer you're not going to be able to
use this again
for uh it's 2 seconds per
five so this is 2
seconds
so 50 is 10
oops
50 uh and this is not Q This is actually
an e so this is an e
ability uh this
is ombat
ability player. man is less than it's a
heavy
skill though it's not really nice to
have skills that take that much Mana
that's kind of crazy
we're going to have to balce all these
anyways I just want to get like rough
like rough
things
um first
nuke player. Manas minus equal to
and player.
qtimer timer equals this is
a a longer cool down I think think like
a 70
I'm realizing I can probably make a lot
of these way simpler so I'm going to
hard code all of them like this for now
before I try to refactor though it'll be
easier uh burst AOE be cheaper
40 play of mana and then the Q timer
will be shorter let's say
stun okay I haven't added the stun yet
so to aoe's so we'll have to do
that Target a
pit
Manas 60
[Music]
Mana Q
timer 80 and this
is W
oops
e and we're going to be able to render
the timer so that'll be a thing that
we'll add in we'll add that today for
sure we'll add H cool Downs to the m to
the uh the HUD
so the AOE damage over
time will be uh this is
a say 20 dot
maybe that
consumes say five Mana
we actually don't need target.
PID player. Mana is less than five
turn man is five this one does not have
a
timer this
channeled tank self
fuel player. man is less than this one
is 40 cost
30 cost on a long cool down let's
say
turn
ler ler
dot q w
timer
50 50 I don't know I'm just making up
numbers
here now this engage Dot
is kind of
interesting because it's a
Teleport um but I think it
works I think it
works we just need to give it uh the
cool down and stuff so if uh player if
uh what is
return if player man is less
than
near you turn and then you you
do and this is a a long cool down as
well skill tank engaged this is uh qw
this is an e
let's make it like a channeled attack or
something
so Target pit
[Music]
return then five
return what we do is we do player
Mana so that's
fine skill carry uh slow and damage this
one's a a standard
skill if the mana's less
than maybe a
40 40
cost move near Target
player
one we don't need that I don't know why
it's recommending that
and then this is skill carry Q This Is
The W
timer and then we do this
AOE turn
and
player W timer Q This is the E
timer almost done and this gives us at
least a base you know basic thing to
start
with man isus 40 and then Q
timer uh is equal to 40
cool we're just adding some
numbers and after this we're going to do
the HUD because the Hud's going to make
it easier to debug so we're going to add
like the little HUD to the bottom of the
screen turn player. Mana is less than
60 turn
man
that's it's a w
[Music]
timer uh and this is channeled
so all this one needs
is what's the goal for this entire
project um the goal for this project is
to implement a miniature MOA that has
pretty much all of the recognizable
features of a mooba like leager DOTA
that I can explain to anybody who has
played leager DOTA in 5 minutes so
pretty simple that has some somewhat
interesting gameplay that has like some
cool strategies and stuff that you could
come up with uh that runs at like a
million frames per second at least on
one CPU core so we can train
reinforcement learning agents incredibly
fast to play this MOA in a way that
looks you know reasonable and
interesting and then you will be able to
like see what the agents have learned
you'll be able to play the mobo with the
RL agents you know to get a sense of how
well they do um you know you'll be have
have them on your team or play against
them whatever it'll be like a nice
little very stripped down miniature
version of open ai5 but that runs really
fast and you can train on one
GPU that's the goal of this project
if
Target if uh player mana's less than
five player mana's m equal
five you're just going to linger a
little
bit
no this just gets to be like two or
something
out okay so let's see if this compiles
and runs and if it does we're going to
build the HUD because I have no idea
what's going on here um and we need the
HUD to like debug cool downs and mana
and stuff
um yeah my Mana goes down when I use the
move buff that's
cool there's this thing that like what
this is supposed to what push me
right yeah that's this thing is supposed
to to push me this doesn't work
perfectly I can tell but yeah it's what
was right here like here something yeah
okay so there's something wrong with the
targeting um but the skills seem to work
at
least let's build the HUD cuz I'm
getting uh sick of fighting bugs so
let's do something easy for a little
bit now we draw
HUD
um
dot we don't really have icons for stuff
yet right so we're going to just have
text at the bottom of the screen for now
and maybe some bars
dot
tangle let's
uh I don't know how big I want to make
this
thing we'll do like I don't
know we'll just put it at like the
bottom left I guess the HUD for
now so like HP
start is equal
to
time
ah four time TI size
top size
times
height
minus
16 size minus
one
sol.
height the width is going to be four *
TI
size and then this is going to
be the height is going to be TI size
I don't know what the hell it thinks
this is supposed to
be maybe I should just make this uh xar
thing
better XY tile
size yeah I should probably just make
this better
yeah that's way easier isn't it so now
we just do draw
bars self. entity is
zero we do tile
size well this is going to just be
four time tile
size and the Y is going to
be tile size minus 2 * self.
height no other way around it's TI size
times self. height minus
see know we'll see what this looks like
probably not great
entities what I've call
it yeah entities just not self done
entities
okay where's my HUD there's no HUD there
so
what do the observations of the other
agents look like Global within area it's
local state so they see um they get a 2d
crop of nearby terrain and stuff and
then they get uh a set of nearby
entities currently the nearest 10
entities that they can see with that are
within a specific
range and um the action space they can
move they can uh they can move um X and
Y those are continuous though they can
be
discretized they can press qw and E so
they have three buttons for skills they
can also attack nearby
agents this is only day4 of the project
and it's you know I'm not going to say
crazy productive days um but it's it's
clipping along at a decent little pace
we have for self. height
here on I defining
height this is
in yeah this is in
tiles
so get the
entity four times TI size
T size times height minus
2 8 is
height which is not used yet we just
really care about the
width oh we set with eight didn't we one
two
yeah so this should be four times tile
size
right can we see it then
maybe I don't know why we don't see
these HUD bars
width height is
672 I'm just going to put this in like
the middle of the screen for now let's
see
450 can I see
it no it still doesn't it it rendered
off screen but but didn't it still
didn't render
missing it's enti is of zero is the
itself
right and put a break point in here and
look can I
width
is it messed this up entities
X Y with
forre I don't freaking know do this
maybe
something okay so now this is just
trolling me because I don't see any
I don't see any rectangles
right so now why is this thing just for
controlling
is this Loop
like no this Loop is
fine there like a break
drawing what the
hell it's actually just trolling me
do these need to be Floats or
something
yeah I actually actually don't know what
the hell's
am there's no way
right why can't I draw a freaking
rectangle
off what they do
Z 128 128 so where's death
W oh God damn it you
stupid
okay yeah
okay so this
is
something self. camera.
Target self. camera. target.
X is there something shorter I can
Target
dox you know what we're just going
int Okay so
there are some health bars up here
they're garbage I don't know why
they're doing that but
um they are
there so I actually just realized that
we don't have to be this
dumb
um that would be a choice that we could
make we could actually just put the HUD
here and then that would be a lot less
stupid
yeah okay so
immediately here's a HUD we're going to
move it and we're going to make it
height
he
okay and then since we do Yus 8 here
we're going to
itus 8 to put it overhead I guess
right
and this goes
away we don't need this this is now six
I
guess which is a little bit of
spacing um and but we're going to
replace it with Min height minus
two and then we're going to set the
height of this bar to
be
16 way better so we have these bars here
let's just move them down to the bottom
We'll add some text
time tile
size height minus 2 times tile
size and then we're going to
do
text
Al if
where is
it
just
boom
strings okay so I see the text but it's
tiny let's make the HUD a little bit
bigger
so this is going to be 24
tall and then this is going to be
like six times tole size I don't know
x y
+
two or
text pause font size
color okay so it just it decided the
default to F to size 10 text for no
particular reason so we're going to do
size 16 text we're going to make this
even a little bit
uh make it like
okay it's a little
cleaner D on by
20 see what's going
on
um let's offset it
by what height over two or
and we have to actually
do +
8 eight and
then Max health max
Mana
Max we do Max
mana and okay so this actually now looks
reasonable I'd
say we have Mana Health right if we go
over
here we can see the Mana bar it's
and let's
um what we do let's put this two from
the
corner and now we're going to
do some icons I guess
um off
color
255 on color is going to
color and we're going to do Q cool
down
equals
uh entity
dot oops
see
cool Q timer W timer e timer
right
timer then this is going to
be
q and now this needs to be
um we made this 10 10
wide it's 12 so let's do
like uh 13
size do HUD
y self.
height
y going to be HUD
y h just you know hack up a quick
so we got 13 times the tile size this
will be 16 * tile size this will be uh
toile size sure why
not um font size is not going to be 20
it's going to be like 40 or
something
large does it do
anything yeah there we
go
Q
boom press
q e
my w should not be randomly changing
that's very
something we need to space them farther
apart I
think um so 13 is fine then like
21 so what's this 8 units 29
spaced
19 or wait is it what 18 yeah
three not
bad it's a little
bit let's just put them one closer to
each
other 17
21 okay so this is
um I've been getting very annoyed with
this obviously but this is
pretty basic reasonable cool down
obviously weird stuff is happening
because these cool Downs are spamming
randomly but you can see when you press
it it turns
green and this is like a super basic
little HUD
right you got your stats on the
bottom
yeah that's
nice uh
yeah I'm pretty happy with how that is
for
now we might make it a little prettier
in the future we might put like some
background or whatever we might like you
know
whatever decent enough for now and we
can go back to debugging some of these
skills I'm going to take a quick second
to use the restroom and clear my head
because the skill bugs have been bugging
me be back in uh oh well I forgot to
make myself a shake for lunch though I'm
out of one second I'll I'll be right
here we've got um we got the basic
UI all we have to do is make the skills
do something
reasonable we can put whatever debug
outputs we want for that
right so just make that do something
reasonable I would like to have a way to
visualize
maybe that'd be nice right to have a way
to determine if something got hit
and then we could draw something on the
screen so we can actually see when our
skills are registering
hit what are you thinking I'm just going
to draw a red box underneath the agents
for now we'll add animations and stuff
after I want to get the basics
working get what the this is
not no player is get entity player do is
hit is false
okay that's what we
wanted and
then inside of attack
reeps this is fine we set everything to
be not hit and then inside of
attack if you take an
attack attack
somewhere where's the attack to
find okay so Target do is hit is
true
now now what we can do is we had this
thing
TI equals z I think we can just do like
this
right oh right
here if entity do is
hit draw a
rectangle will be
128 now
255 okay so now maybe we will be able to
see what the heck is going
on we forgot to rebuild this so we're
not going to be able to see squat of
course let's fix that
let's
go oh we can see who's getting hit here
right there two puffers getting
hit it's the blue one
ones now they're all getting hit we're
all getting hit by the tower right we
can see
it your position can be off by up to one
tile because we're you know you can be
like right between the edge of the tile
or
whatever so we can see
this appears to be working right
okay there the puffers
go and uh they now come for
me now can I just boost away though is
the question
whoop yes I
can I can totally just boost
away and can I hit this
thing no I can't hit this thing it's not
letting me
attack so it just hit me but I can't hit
it so something is wrong with the the
human targeting it looks like like the
UI that I'm using to Target but not the
other targeting I like how you can get
the puppers to follow you it's pretty
cool see they'll just follow me where
ever I
well maybe it's not the
um it could be the observation
computation hold
on I did refactor that earlier today
so do you slid you play any
mobas um I
played I played enough League to get
ranked
and I played like 50 no maybe a 100
hours of DOTA I don't have that many
hours in mobas though I have a ton of
hours in MMOs not too many in
mobas though I will say when I do when I
do end up when I did play them I like
spammed all the videos and stuff spammed
all the spammed all the content so
like I have an idea of what is supposed
to to
happen even if I'm absolutely terrible
at it uh at
them I have like some idea to how well
League support and bottom are supposed
to
interact I have some idea of how like
roaming characters work I have some idea
about like how Tempo is supposed to
progress nothing great
but I'm definitely not qualified to be
designing like a good MOBA for people
but hopefully I can come up with
something that's you know reasonably
I don't see anything wrong
here Target
PID I mean I can also check the PID map
maybe I mess that up
right Let's do let's add
um let's just draw on the pit map a
little bit
to1 well we actually don't need to
because we just have a value error so
what we're going to do
Circle this can go at the bottom
actually so we put it on
top and it's going to be
a a green
circle it's going to be tile
size over four let's just do
this do you remember what got you
interested in RS oh I can tell that
story hold
on um let me one
second this seems to be working right
like these all have green circles like
they no leak there no green circles
being
leaked okay um so the thing that got me
interested in reinforcement learning was
neural
MMO um I came up with the idea
long time ago I tried it like a couple
of times before I really got it solid
and I knew anything of what I was doing
I mean I first tried this thing in high
school I tried it again in undergrad
like as a freshman didn't know what I
was doing and then I the time I it stuck
was sophomore summer which
is seven eight years ago almost eight
years ago now I think maybe eight years
on the dot
um and I got this idea in my head right
that like reinforcement learning it
solves go it's solving Atari um I didn't
know it would solve DOTA then but you
know open AI was already working on it
uh and the thing that RL couldn't solve
was like some of the high level
reasonings that is present in more
complex games so I just figured hey what
if I build a really awesome simulator
and throw AI at that and I just started
hacking on it from there and I just kept
hacking on it for like seven
years and and uh that is how all the
stuff that I've built got
built a lot of fun stuff happened um my
thesis is my thesis
online should be
okay so my thesis is online here this is
like 170 page document that contains
most of my work but it also contains
like a few page Preamble with a better
version of the story that I just told so
that's there
now maybe instead of doing this circle
here we can
do what it
Target Target
PID entity. pit equal Target
H I still don't know why it won't let me
attack stuff
it's getting these attacks here it's
just not like targeting them correctly
and I think that this is probably what's
wrong with all the skills cuz I'm
testing all of them on this human
controlled character and if I'm just not
able to Target stuff then yeah of course
the skills don't work that's why like
the selfcast skills the heals seem to
work
right I think as soon as we fix this
they're all just going to magically
to okay so it's setting attack to stuff
which is PID minus one it says so that
shouldn't be able to do that I
think
because if the nearest Target hold
on it shouldn't be able to set to
something that has PID negative one
so I have an error in this logic here
somewhere let's see if anybody spots it
before
me so when you started it was just a
game and then you thought it would be a
good application for no it didn't start
it as a game
my motivations have always been
long-term progress in Ai and I just
thought that I've thought that MMOs are
the perfect medium for training AI
because there are these really huge
complex
all-encompassing World simulators and
really if you think about it there's
nothing in gaming that approaches the
level of richness you get in an MMO
right like sure like the momentto moment
play and and uh skill
might be higher in a MOA but like mobas
don't take place over thousands of hours
for one game right players learn more
and more over thousands of hours but
it's not like one continuous run where
the world is ever
evolving um and like new players are
arriving markets are shifting there's so
much complexity and richness in an MMO
so that's what I wanted to capture for
RL and I mean I made a decent dent in it
with neural MMO it's nowhere near the
skill SC of a full scale MMO but I think
I did a pretty good job for a you know
underresourced single author I mean
single developer on the thing and uh
there's a whole bunch of tech in RL I
had to make in order for that to happen
over the last seven years and uh it's
really it's laid the groundwork for
everything you see here as well because
all the experience and all the
techniques and stuff for making really
good high performance Sims for RL came
from neural MMO like everything is easy
after neural MMO because that project
was so ridiculously complicated that now
everything is Easy by
zbug yeah I've seen neurl MMO on for
years you're well thank you and there's
neural MMO's not over there is still
followup work
um there is still some follow-up work on
it I will say that it will be out soon I
just need to finish it I've been putting
it
so what the heck is wrong here
it set something to PID negative
one which means that nearest Target is
not
none nearest Target gets set
here but if Target pit is negative one
they shouldn't be
possible you said you were motivated by
long-term progress in AI before you
started
it so what sparked that
motivation it's like what sparks the
motivation for the holy Grail right
um I guess I guess I didn't always have
like the crazy AI views I have now I
guess when I started I just thought that
the tech was really cool and like the
thing about Ai and CS in general is it's
really the only field where you can sit
down with a laptop and just change the
world overnight if you write the right
code if you're good enough um you don't
really need any other
resources there's just always the
opportunity to do that if if you're good
enough um so that was the initial draw
and then as it sort of became more clear
that people were getting more and more
serious about like building really good
generally capable AI uh that became the
the sort of the driving force behind it
right I see
like I see AI as having the potential to
just catapult us through 10,000 years of
human society progress in a year um
and I mean that seems like a
self-evident goal to me right it's a
Holy
Grail not expressing all this Fair all
that eloquently at the moment mind you
pretty tired but that's the general gist
of
on
no stop it
Windows okay so as soon as I put my
cursor on the screen it does this
values shortest
distance is there
it still pit negative
one hold
what the hell how's this getting
negative
ones okay you know what screw it we're
going to
do best Target
equals none we're going to just re redo
stuff until we make it
work if best Target is
none best Target is target
continue
wise otherwise distance to Target is
going to be square
root
best there
something something like this
right target is none Target pits
negative
one if best Target is none Target pits
otherwise best Target P something
something like like this just
okay okay so we're getting all these
different attack
options but then the pids are all
negative one somehow
right can I like go through here
and then I have this is pit negative one
as
well oh but this is Target pit is
negative one so this is best best
target. pit which should be right
whoops they get stuck if you lure them
which is
funny so now it says that I have a
reasonable PID it says setting attack to
one which is PID 20 right
now we can go into the C code or the
scon
rather and we can
see aha
whether this attack is
reasonable attacking Target PID with
health we're going to compile this and
we're going to see whether we get to the
correct attack function and somehow it
fails from
there or if we don't even get to this
function ah I'm being mobbed by puffer
fish
attacking 23 with 2500 Health
right then attacking
20 so it says I'm
attacking so for some reason the attack
just isn't going through
okay if Target
do let's say
if uh
player PID
Z
so let's see if it for some reason
thinks that we're on the same team as
the enemy turret
think oops let's get away from these
guys okay my team is Z Target team is
one right so I should be inflicting
damage I'm not inflicting any damage
let's see why that is
here
o I'm getting an idea as to what this
might
be I'm going to be really annoyed if I'm
right
oops okay so it says attacking for five
damage
right but nothing happens I bet you
we're attacking a copy of the target
instead of the
target get player
OB gives us
Target
yep found
it so
stupid so
stupid in fact we shouldn't even do this
because get player OB this the only
place we call
fine now it's going to work and now
everything's going to be great
and we're going to remove all the
prints player OB does return a reference
to the observed one The observed one is
in a separate struct the observation of
the agent is in a different place from
the agent it is a
copy so that was the mess
up I did that during the refactor I'm
sure
boom
I think we can just kill one these
right watch this boom yeah we totally
did we just did a we can do a a TP
strike right boom you see that that was
a Teleport to Target and
strike that's pretty sweet right
boom we have an assassinate
function interesting that you can use it
when I think it's allowing me to Target
myself with it so we got to fix
that um
but yeah pretty
cool
assassinate does a big chunk of damage
we got the self heal
here we got the speed
boost which is
channeled that's kind of legit isn't
it
support okay okay now that we actually
have the code not being horribly broken
let's commit all this and let's I've got
it's almost six we're going to spend a
little more than an hour on this um and
we're going to just make this sick as
hell that's going to be the goal
okay so this is where we actually get
some good content because this is going
to be fun H I've been so annoyed so many
stupid bugs today and it's just because
I'm half asleep I swear like if I were
actually paying attention I wouldn't be
making this many bugs
but H so tired
okay here are all the skills that we
have to test out um
We There are a few things we can do
right there needs to be balance to these
and balancing is going to be hard um
so we can try to get the mechanics right
now but the thing is a lot of the
mechanics and like the feel of these is
going to be dependent on balance
so ah
let's start by like making sure all the
skills work okay so like this assassin
TP damage
um TP for damage takes Mana what's the
thing that we're using at the moment
there was one of them that was not
correctly consuming Mana this AOE
heal yeah so this one needs to take
and uh player dot what is it support
hook heel so this is W timer is equal to
40 or like 60 or whatever we're going to
set it
to
works Bo W works it looks
like uh the cool down does not work
works can I just press q no I can no
longer just press Q randomly can I press
Q on my own Tower yeah I can press Q on
my own Tower that's not terrible though
you can blink to your own thing
ah so this skill is taking a uh the
assassinate is doing a w cool down as
Y and it's supposed to be a w cool down
right I just gave it in the wrong
order
yeah okay
so we want to have this is the support
usually right
so we'll try this support stun
AE
when not doing animations
yet we might do some basic animations
we're going to need to at least do some
visual indicators we're going to see how
nice we make them uh some of the
movement things are kind of animated
already you'll see like the push in the
H the hook is kind of animated because
it's a channel skill
him he's totally
stunned is he Perma stunned the hell
what
happened W is my AOE heal W works I'm
not seeing the cool Downs
here so we'll have to check on
that why is it when I get in range of
the tower
H so if I'm in range of the tower it
actually activates the cool down let's
see why that is
then we could make a generic skill
function I guess for all of these then
we'd have to debug one function instead
of
15 would have a bunch of uh args
but maybe not the
worst I guess we can start on
that H it's
hard hard to
do really confused about the
timers for
qwe what the
heck what could possibly be resetting my
w timer
actually you might be able to hook
Towers right now come to think of it can
you hook Towers
we're going to have to make movement be
click based I think instead of drag
based Maybe
H so hard to tell what the heck is going
wrong with these
we do know that stuff is randomly
screwing with our timers right
update coold Downs
wait did I just see what I thought I saw
no I thought it was setting them to
zero maybe we can figure it
out come on what could it possibly be
why I just stunned myself first of all
right I think I Perma stunned
myself so that is a clue
right W
I don't know if that's like an out of
bounds or
something but W is getting randomly
screwed with and my stun timer is
not player logic oh if you're
stunned you don't get
updates so let's put that down here
first of all
here stun is going to be entity. stun
Tim uh it's going to be
at 25 HUD Yus
20 and then it's going to be in size
20 okay
then we're going to have move
timer
25 it's going to be at HUD
Y and see let's see if we can get
something with
this okay this actually looks pretty
nice so we've got first of all I noticed
that these move timers this move timer
is getting [ __ ] with
randomly which is not
me so I stunned myself
here and then you see the stun timer
decreases like that right
works none of the cool Downs seem to
work
though ah if I cast it on this enemy it
does work though which is
odd right consistently works if I cast
it on an
enemy let's see if we can get a clue
from that even though I didn't see
anything in the code that would be that
would make that make
return if Mana is less than
60 return
okay so this has to be on pit zero
because I'm I'm able to Target
myself and the stun timer
works but the E timer only works if I
attack why is that
I see nothing on here that would mess
with that but the fact that timers are
getting randomly screwed
with that leads me to believe
that something is very wrong with them
Target layer Mana is decreased then the
Mana decrease is correctly applied
the timer doesn't seem to be but timers
are also getting randomly messed
with is something like writing over in
memory or something
nuts that wouldn't make sense like how
would that
dot no no nowhere is there a Target mess
uh is anything messing with the timer of
something labeled targ
get we're getting the player here
correctly we're updating status and cool
down
this I just
disable all the other things from using
skills but me and maybe then Nobody
messes with my cool down
okay so let's see if while I'm just
walking around if any of my timers get
messed
with I have not pressed any
buttons usually they get messed with
around here
they should be dying
right
yeah so if I press this in the vicinity
here then I get the cool down
right if I press Q if I press E I use
the
Mana if I press E I use the Mana and I
get the cool down if I press
Q Q is the only one that doesn't have a
cool down but Q is a channeled skill Q
doesn't have a cool down so that is my
clue my clue is that the cooldowns only
occur when I'm not targeting
myself which is very
heel it's not even when
I'm targeting my myself
because here I'm targeting player comma
player not even player comma Target so
I'm aoeing myself it's when I'm getting
hit that stuff
activates
huh you know
what I have a suspicion
okay I bet I figured it out
here and if I'm right I'm going to be
mad
you I didn't rebuild it did
I no I did rebuild
out okay I thought it was a I thought it
was a struck bit packing a struck bite
packing error it is not a struck bite
packing error it is still the case
though that I only get cool Downs when
I'm under attack which makes absolutely
no sense
on let me just make sure I'm not just
printing it wrong that would be very
dumb
okay I'm literally I'm just
freaking literally just doing it wrong
it's so stupid
okay just a draw error it's not even a
logic error it's a draw
error okay there was nothing crazy this
is just me being dumb
it can't believe I didn't catch that
that's so stupid
there's your cool
down there your cool
down
cool so this now
works uh it screwed up my alignment
thanks super
maven screwed up the alignment of these
so this is supposed to be 25 and then
this is supposed to
right let's go get a let's go get one of
these
here
like no
work Q is the hook W is the heel is the
stun
okay so you do actually get
stunned I don't know why this puffer is
man I don't know how it's been so hard
to debug these skills I thought this
would be
easy I probably need to just start
making
um making some functions or whatever
well okay what I can
do I know what I can do I can
make let's make the this an INT okay and
this is going to be return minus one
one we're going to make attack return
and error
one turn one
so now what we can do this is going to
simplify all the skills and reduce the
uh the chances for uh for bugs
and we're going to do this for like all
of these functions so this is going to
be an INT
return this is going to be an
INT okay this is minus
one this
since all the pushes are channeled I can
actually make this way simpler I
think right yeah I can make this way
simpler so float amount
times
biest okay
and return self. move to Dy and DX like
this okay so this is now good
and this is going to help us a lot
because we're going to just be able to
avoid a bunch of useless
I don't like that we have to double code
the uh the Mana cost like this but I
don't have a good way around this
that's way better
right cuz now we can tell if we're
getting attacked and only then if the
attack goes through and only then you
lose mana and you get the cool down so
you can't waste skills and we don't have
to check the pids because stuff like
attack is going to check it for us right
do you could technically even do like
that but I think that's too
confusing I think it's just best to do
like this
let me make sure something is reasonable
here think I heard a
yeah this saves us a lot of
oh we can
do hold
okay these are getting to be less
wasteful at least these
lines like this
right if
feels appropriate here because it's like
this joint
and we no longer have to check against
ourself because the the other check will
uh take care of that
[Music]
I think this one actually does need a
separate team check
work how about
this if
Mana but only
CD uh if attack is valid okay that's
good right that's not bad for like a
more
complicated a more complicated
Dot and this is not really a DOT the way
that I have it now right
we're going to have
to rework
this this
one um okay let's look at the retreat
and
pushes you back from the Target by uh by
one that's
good slow and
damage looks
fine this AOE it's fine
and we did have to uh we didn't finish
this one so this is assassinate
TP this is the same as before right
where if you fail to move
near you return but then you consume the
Mana
right and then
this
fine and then the assassinate move
buff is just
two give you a move timer one even can't
flick it
step okay um we are now down to below
lines which is not
you don't see what skills the player
has because it's not we're not going to
have it take function pointers right
I mean it's ugly but it's not
complicated so I don't think I'm going
to care too much about
it
um okay uh
let's let's test it I
guess we can just uh
switch variables around right in order
to test different
characters
oops Yeah we can totally just to test
different characters switch some stuff
and kind of
gross we're going to have to refactor
I'm sure
assignable
andal one
one turn one
puffer
boom
we've got the minion clear spell
right we've got the whoops we've got the
blink
teleport and then our speed boost
blink we've got the minion clear which
is the AOE we've got the speed boost so
this well this one works
perfectly the assassin class assassin
class feels good
good um Z
one and then this
is so this is zero here we're going to
try what do we have burst AOE burst AOE
stun so it's missing the
stun um
hey pdubs
welcome we
are actually doing very well well here
um have you seen this project
around whoops this needs to be no
stun we use AOE anywhere
huh peaked at the streaming code a few
times well
welcome uh we
are doing some cool stuff I will
say uh I'm kind of surprised how quick
this is
arguments and AOE was it player Target
radius Damage
Done player Target radius damage stun
right
SP
Rus damage stun
yes it's
done that's probably
it hopefully this works and we can see
some cool stuff yeah this is day four is
the stream well it's in the Stream title
um medium productive days I'm going to
say I've been kind of tired the running
is
rough but
uh hopefully we'll have a cool demo here
I mean I'm just testing some new stuff
out okay perer stop body blocking
me so I forget what this character even
does I think it's got a nuke of some
type oh yeah that's a big
nuke yeah that's it's got a big nuke
okay uh let's try this
boom
okay is there another wave here forget
what this even does I think W is an AOE
and then e is an AOE stun so let's see
if we can stun the next wave before it
hits
me they
goop they
stun can't tell if they're
stunning definitely clear
them not sure if this STS work yet we'll
see about
that um let me see what this was
supposed to
be does RL
rayb if you're confusing the name this
has nothing to do with like any skill
Ray and rlb completely separate
thing um let's have some vendor some
third party
in I think it's open CV no not open what
am I talking about open GL I think
um I mean RB is really awesome it is a
single file C library with bindings for
every Library so the library is just a C
file it's really sweet
so this is supposed to be a burst nuke a
burst AOE and a burst AOE stun
nuke burst
AOE to 200 and then a burst AOE
stun which is
supposed to have a pretty chunky stun
duration on it
right in a radius of
two so in
AOE Target stun
timer is equal to stun
Let's
see we haven't done attack ranges yet to
be fair
okay it's weird that um this should not
be able to consume
Mana so my my Q is consuming Mana my w
is consuming Mana
Mana at
all so is something just screwy here
maybe I'm just not casting what I think
I
am
um burst nuke burst AOE burst AOE stun
huh
uh that looks right to
it's if you're targeting yourself you're
on your same team so like you should be
they should not be consuming Mana let me
see why the heck this is consuming Mana
if player. pit is equal to zero
print nuke Target
PID set nuke Target PID
um by player pit now
wait I don't know
I'd like to know what the heck it thinks
it's doing
here this is supposed to be like
um I don't know some mid
character I haven't played enough mobas
probably like Alina or
something so okay there's nobody around
here right
nuke
huh nuke
zero nuke
zero so it literally it knows that the
target PID is zero but that's my
PID pid's character type these is a pit
is player ID it's just the index uh you
know unique identifier zero is the uh
human controlled character in this case
so basically it's not supposed to do
this
um skill
first let me try this cep
if
rent layer.
PID r
if player.
PID
a I'm just trying to see if cython is
doing something weird with in's
Bulls why are there
nonzero hardcoded pids
then um well every every entity in the
game has its own unique
PID
um what do you mean where are their
hardcoded pits
they're not hardcoded
like I mean there are certain unique
things in the game right hold on so if I
hit
Q you get nuke zero did I forget to
rebuild I bet I forgot to
rebuild no I didn't forget to re wait
what oh I did it on the AOE that's
fine oh those um yeah that's because I
need a way to detect which I don't have
a decent way to detect what hero type
you are so I'm just deciding like zero
is uh like zero is team one's support
and five is team two support and so on
and so
forth okay so this is nuke
zero AOE
1 AOE 2 2
one okay this doesn't help me very much
um let's do this one first
here
interet do
[Music]
so they're functionally being used as
character types oh I see what you mean
yeah I guess kind of um this is
temporary this is me being uh this is me
hacking something I just added this
today like there were there were no
character types until today and I've
been having a ton of trouble getting the
skills to work as I want
easy okay so
like now do I get a decent
debug okay nuke
2 minus
interet I guess negative one is
truthy is that a
Thing If player am I stupid or is this
like interpreting negative one is truthy
because this returns an INT I printed
out the integer it's
-1 and and right underneath
it if R I'm printing out R and it's
negative
right it
is you got to be kidding me
well that's that's
garbage
um what's the canonical thing does c
have a native Boolean
type underscore you have to include it
it's
not what's what's the idiomatic C thing
to do to do do you do um do you check
against negative one or do you use
Bulls okay I hate that I think I'm going
to use the error codes that's
I mean I guess technically
it's let me just make sure there's not a
post about B being
slow no okay I guess since it's syon we
can use BN right
uh I don't like how it doesn't show up
as uh in my highlights as a native type
but
is this like terribly unidiomatic or is
this fine
okay this one is actually supposed to be
an INT because it Returns the target
into
AOE so B into
AOE we can
do um
excited to hear how this develops catch
you later yeah see you
pdubs thanks for dropping
by the other folks here pdubs is the
original creator of the Pokemon Red
project which I am now sponsoring
compute
for um awesome awesome project got some
awesome people working on
it I'd like to be doing more on it
personally but I've been doing all this
other
stuff okay
so maybe this is now reasonable
right I no longer use Mana for things
that are not
boom okay that's
nice um the stun doesn't seem to do
anything I like that I have this nuke
but stun doesn't seem to do
much I can spam it on stuff but
um let me see
maybe I can make it easy to aim like
this uh nope not like that
though okay so for some reason this one
doesn't work
well we kind of chopped up all the code
on this didn't
we yeah so let's
AOE skill I don't know why it like it
changes args on you that's so pretty
bad okay it's fine and then the burst
stun
here it checks self
AOE and it inflicts a stun
int or was it B
AOE in
stun target. stun
timer equals
stun
okay see if I fixed
um skill burst AOE stun
qwe skill burst AOE
stun
does does not remove my Mana meaning
that this dides not go through
oh greater than equal
zero there we
go actually we can make this simpler
right if damage greater than zero we can
also do if stun greater than
zero no we can't it has to be part of
the
attack Yeah It's Tricky I mean this is
garbage code like this little section's
garbage code we're going to have to
refactor this welcome back as
well got another half hour or so in me
here should get some cool stuff in that
time though we're very close to having
this
done lots of stupid bugs today lots and
lots of stupid
bugs okay here we
go
so good it doesn't take my Mana now how
about now
boom I'm pressing it and when I press W
it
works looks like you made a lot of
progress yeah there's been good progress
ress um damage greater than or equal to
zero
right
wait
Tac let me see so this returns B into
Tac pit is negative one or
true this looks like this should work
right done
St player. pit is equal
to
zero the UI was super quick to do it's
the main thing is all the skills and
then the big refactor from today was to
use um pointers instead of pids
everywhere possible
since we end up getting pointers from
pids anyways it's just one less layer of
indirection so one less place to be
stupid okay let me out blocking
Boom for some reason this e does not
work and the stun is not triggered
here it's a burst AOE stun
right you're in AOE not I don't have an
AOE stun so burst AOE stun right here it
calls AOE and then the last ARG is a
stun so this is damage and this is
stun so this is the Sig that we're using
right
here and if we look
right like
here it's player Target radius is two
damage is zero stun is 40
do let's just do this I have I'm not
sure of anything
he
we and
uh let's see
this is such a garbage
function it'd be really funny if I
actually just like loaded the DOTA map
into
this oh that's interesting
so nothing came
up it's based around your cursor um it's
based around the nearest character dear
cursor rather so this is interesting um
nothing came up until I hit the other
AOE
qwe V burst stun is this even getting
triggered
I think it
is okay so burst sun is definitely when
I press down it triggers a bunch of
these so but it doesn't trigger the AOE
until I press that button and then it
triggers all the
AOE okay so we know that this function
is getting
called first
AOE but for some
reason wait oh my gosh
why
so so
stupid
ah it's
painful
why why was that
there I hate
ah damn it and now I'm all freaking
loopy from having just been like working
on this thing I forgot to get lunch
today
of course being
stupid get stunned puffers get stunned
ha stay there and be
permanently are they Perma
stunned
what I think perm done the puffers so uh
may as well just like test out the
single Target nuke which works the
multi-target nuke which also works but
it's overtuned as [ __ ]
it shouldn't be a 40 second stun it
should be a 40 tick
stun oh I think I have an idea
um yep as I expected
no uh here you got to update the status
first so it was a Perma Stone but only
on
creeps now I think that this is going to
feel good I think this is going to be
the second character we've got that
definitely feels
good you've got a single Target nuke
you've got a pretty nice AOE and then
you've got an AOE stun so this is the
supposed to be like the mid lane
character let's get ready to provide
some util with the AOE
stun and then we can nuke AOE and then
we can provide you know the tower nuke
with the single
tar
boom we can basically just solo a tower
so this is still way over two
tuned um but hey I think it feels good
little balanced but feels good good
job uh we're we're going to do this one
next
cat you know this this stupid cat that
you don't even move your mouse you just
press buttons and you
win who oh okay so we got BK we got this
teleport
assassinate like this right boom
teleport assass
I can't tell if the assassinate is doing
damage it is definitely teleporting us I
don't think it's doing damage we've got
that self heal which just heals 200 and
then I think we have um a minion AOE
clear cuz this is like the jungle
character is it the jungle character we
on the tank no we're on the tank this is
supposed to be an AOE Dot
so if I go near the tower no my AOE dot
doesn't seem to work so cell fuel works
teleport Works let's go figure out
what's wrong with it
so I have it centered on myself
here and I'm
saying Center on target
right and then you go look through all
the nearby ones and you attack them that
seems
fine and Mana goes down if you can do it
the cell Fel works and then the engage
dot okay this has a big note to rework
it
um this no longer needs to be equal
equal negative 1 that's why because this
is now a
beant if TP is Val I think that this is
actually kind of okay uh oh right it's
the the problem is that the uh the TP
this is not a DOT this is just like a
clone of the assassinate I think
okay well since you're here you get to
tell me how I should fix this um so the
issue is that if you have an engage
damage over time like you can't the
teleport is instant but then like
there's a channel component to it and
you need to hold the button so like you
can't have something that both jumps you
in and does a damage over time
um it could be
a hold on I could potentially
do it could be an engage AOE
do I can do a Channel or I can do a
Teleport I can't do both to be fair do
we really need multiple
engages well yeah the tank should have
an engage right
maybe he has an AOE pull that would be
really cool
I gotta find a better way than just
adding more parameters to AOE
what the hell is this auto complete
that's so
right yeah this definitely going to be
interesting for
coordination Target PID
the amount that you
pull so Target pit
maptive one you get the
entity and then you
do up hole
uh it's a fixed distance displ
displacement
um but the thing
is technically if you Channel a pull
you'll get a smooth animation I don't
know how to do it in a blink though in a
blink it's a little
awkward should that be pull
Target player I don't think so let me
see you yeah no cu the pull here the
pull here calls
push so I could do it that way or I
could just call pull
here I think this is
correct player Target
amount I think I have it
right I don't know
yeah it's getting it's weird that the
code is not good okay that some of the
code in this in this file is good most
of it is
not yet it will be
is AOE
pull and it's going to be a one pull for
now just to test
engage dot cannot
[Music]
convert working code is better than
beautiful V hey I mean the thing is
is most of this is not
terrible
um I don't think it's a problem like I
don't think that it's a bad idea to just
be implementing everything in like one
800 line file even I think that's
perfectly
fine
um it's just that some of the actual
logic and the functions Is Not
Great okay so you can teleport to
stuff h oh look did I just do it I think
I did right boom yeah they did that I
think it
works I actually would way prefer
everything like especially for a project
that's going to be maybe a thousand
lines I'd almost way prefer to have one
file with really procedural brain dead
simple logic than um have like you know
10 files with a million useless
abstractions
tell I mean I can set the pull to a
ridiculous amount
I really can't
tell I think it's going to be hard to
make that feel good um maybe a push
would be
since like creeps tend to follow you
anyways and
stuff cuz then you could jump in like on
an ally right and you could maybe push
them out of the
way yeah yeah so you could blink you
could blink onto an ally right and you
could push enemies off of them that
actually would be way
cooler so let's see
working Does placement work on stun
targets
yeah it
would it's just not getting called I can
tell you for sure
um centered on player y player X
it blink stun and push would be crazy
strong
did I even rebuild
this hold on
target. team is player
team being able to pull a team is
reasonable too as a support yeah that's
it's there for a
support like that's what we have it for
originally wait do I did I do this wrong
um
push looks like this should be correct
let's try this
out I got to order dinner in a few
minutes and then I got to go when it's
here freaking
starving good progress though
no I'm not getting like the
oomph that I want out of
this this is supposed to be a blink
strike
right blink
Works self heal
Works self feels really
nice be easier to give the creeps like
like 10K
Health
um I think it's like obviously not
working I'm just trying to figure out if
I can tell
why easiest would be to make him not
move to be honest that would make it
level okay so here are the
puffers boom
working let's see if it thinks it's
working
creep navigation can be overriding it
it's not getting this is not getting
printed unless I forgot to rebuild which
I
didn't so why is it not
getting
AE
player 4 and 2 right
and then AOE
pull oops
rebuild we're so close to having
something cool here
though after this test I got to order
food I'll still be on here though until
it gets here
ah so there's
no no recognition whatsoever of
anything okay
player did I do this math wrong is
it negative
radius this the same isn't
it get entity Target PID
me minus
radius we're not calling it with a
radius zero
right
or
2.0 and we
pull M
map d
y X+
oh
what it's literally not
even it's not okay is
this hold
on move to AE pull hold on it might not
even be getting here move
near
if not
self. move
near
ah it's supposed to
be supposed to be
I mean I'm just like hungry and tired at
this point so I should stop I'm going to
order my food I'm going to make sure
this works hold
now now let's see if we can get
something cool to happen
did that put them out of position yeah
it did I just saw
puers Boom
we knock him out of position a bunch
right
boom yeah that totally knocks him out of
position I think things move too fast at
the moment
right but yeah that makes
push and now we just have um
well I guess the first one needs a
little work but we'll do this one
here so they've got a retreat slow a
slow damage and
slow uh carry slow damage
and slow and damage and
AE I think we're going to end up making
the slows
stronger so we've got a
treat
slow okay it's got an
AOE there's a yep that's a nice Retreat
slow
right we it launches you back out
slow damage slow okay let's tune it a
little bit I
think I think um this one
here is is going to
be
push it's we're going to just do it
twice I
think
[Music]
turn we're going to and then we're just
going to do push
modifier and uh this has got to cost
more than that this has got to cost like
and then player. W timers got to have
like some sort of a cool down on
it try
that oh actually that's that's still not
enough
push you need like 1.5 I
think so it's going to essentially it's
going to try to move you 1.5 cells it's
going to try to move you two times so if
you can't bump back all the
once one does not inflict
damage
see that's pretty cool and if I go like
this ah that goes very
far that pushes you way farther than it
should doesn't it
oh I'm not actually enforcing the W
timers is all
three but yeah it's going to do
1.53
so like you want to like retreat from
something
that's pretty nice
right and you just spend energy as you
need
to then what we have we have uh AOE we
have a slow and we have just a simple
AOE simple AOE is simple
AOE doesn't do a ton of damage
good for
farming and let's see if we can slow one
of these
guys alt there are only three
skills at the moment we could
technically add four for an
ult might be cool
the SS would be we should totally add
alts you're right e
okay so the reason you can't see it is
because it does too much damage I
think does 250 damage
right or what 100
some point not needed right now yeah I
agree welcome link
key been some good stream today good
progress um this is a 877 line scyon
file that did not exist before Monday so
that's always nice
slower randomly found this live what
language is this in um it is a mix of
python and cython pretty much the whole
environment for the game is in scyon but
all of the surrounding infrastructure
the training neuronet stuff and so on
and so forth minus a few performance
critical pieces are in
Python this is uh well this will be an
ultra high performance Sim that runs at
a million frames per second by the time
I'm done with it no idea how fast it
runs now haven't optimized it at
all uh million seconds per CPU core I
should say and then the goal is to get
this training at a million frames per
second that might be kind of hard but at
least uh 100 at least like hundreds of
thousands and I just I did see that the
slow was just working a moment ago so
we're good on this this character feels
pretty good
um the slows need a little bit more
range I think on them to be impactful
but we can do that so this one is feels
good only one that's left is the uh the
first one which is a little
support okay so this is a
channel uh you can keep
pulling at a one unit per 15 mana and
you can just keep casting this it looks
like that's good um support has has an
AOE
heal which is has a cool down which is
reasonable and they have a a heavy
stun this should be a very heavy stun so
we're going to put a 60 on this and a
cool
down also this thing is open source this
is on um GitHub is puffer AI puffer lib
go ahead and give the repo a star on
your way in helps me out a whole
bunch um but yeah all the stuff I'm
deving is free open source fun
got okay so this is not what I wanted to
do is the opposite of what I wanted to
do this is a pull towards a thing
right all this looks really cool where
should I go if I ever wanted to learn to
code to learn code
well something like this would probably
take quite a while um the game component
of it is not all that hard um the hard
thing is designing this for I mean all
of the the players in this game are
going to be controlled by neural
networks that are trained with
reinforcement learning uh so designing
for that ultra high performance is hard
basic game stuff is uh to new new people
I just generally recommend uh whatever
time you're going to spend on it you
spend like 20% of the time on like
online course formal resources uh don't
use like dumb boot camps the top courses
from like Stanford
Harvard Harvard but yeah Stamford MIT
really for Tech uh those are
online um So 20% of time on that and 80%
of time just building stuff is what I
say can we
pull oh I think we can pull right
towers you can pull the towers cuz I
forgot to to account for
oops I guess there's something there
that's
wonky
um now we're not doing pulling Towers
we're not hooking towers around that
would be
nuts it would be very funny but I think
it would break the game
right I'm really tempted to leave it in
but like
it would 100% break the
game the RL agents you know you're kind
of right that the RL agents would come
up with some crazy stuff fine I'll leave
it it's a
feature it's a
stay well these all feel good
then we've actually managed to get
um we've actually managed like they have
to be balanced and stuff but we've got
five hero classes or whatever that feel
pretty good
SS that'd be
funny I had the back this in the
background most of my work day hey
thanks for for uh sticking around yeah I
saw the one person on Twitch that's cool
to
see I mean then you've seen all the
stuff and you've heard plenty of me
bitching about stupid
I like the
assassin the Assassin feels the best to
assassin I think that's my best
one it's super simple but it's like
really fun
oh yeah we need to do slow heal over
time as well well we also have to
implement coold Downs properly there's
lots of stuff to
do um so the Assassin has this sweet
move speed boo boost he's got this
freaking awesome teleport of course he
gets merked if he gets caught like that
but next time if I can follow a rain uh
what is it it's it says right under here
it's like support assass in burst damage
there's a tank and then there's a
carry yeah like the mobility feels
really good like you can just like
boom
right it's just a straight move speed
buff but it feels really
good when do you add jungle uh there's a
class that would that would work this
this actually this class right here this
assassin works well as a jungler he has
an AOE that only works on creeps for
clear and then he can do [ __ ] like this
boom and just like take one
out of course the creep clear just kind
of makes the wave obsolete but you know
if you use it on a player
character this is this teleport you saw
like does a big chunk of damage
puff and we'll have to set all the Mana
thresholds so you can do cool Combos and
stuff like WQ and whatever like jump and
like spam some stuff be cool all right
here puffers go
on Boom nice Saye
boom jungle instead of Bot
mitt yeah yeah I've got to add the map
but this class here would function as
jungle something's gr something's Jun
over here um but yeah this class will
function as a jungle once I change the
map and add some neutrals
basically we got to put different base
stats for different classes we got to do
cool Downs there's lots of stuff there
to
do but uh it's pretty nice it's pretty
nice
this
is hold
on if we go to
perer as and SD I feel like I stared my
own I stared at my own bugs all day and
watch and watching you quash yours is
therapeutic well hey they're easier to
fix when you're not working on a giant
pain in the
project are you going to hardcode
classes or have a yaml or such to easily
add new
ones uh there's not really an easy way
to add new ones because like you need to
write arbitrary code for new skills
that's the
thing um so it's in any config right now
thank you for the Stars today folks it's
gone uh it's gotten quite a
few this growth is awesome to see
uh it's in any config it's in puffer lib
environments ocean is our set of first
party environments so this also has the
grid environments that we made on stream
and it also has uh the snake environment
that we did on stream it's got mooba and
here's the
code this files 400 lines
of I don't know whatever the heck is in
here
and then we've got the actual or is it
the C code or the scon code is
bad if anybody's got any quick RL
questions I'll answer those at the
moment if not uh I'll be signing off
because food will be here in a moment I
forgot to make lunch today so I'm
absolutely
starving hold
onup
thing there we
go
yeah I wonder if there there's any cool
progress update I could post real quick
on
Twitter localize the rewards in Pokemon
but it's really bad hardly beat gym
one I don't know what you mean by
localize the
rewards I don't know what you mean by
localized rewards than okay
oh
um probably linky that means that you've
like tuned your hyper parameters really
aggressively over the last several
months for the exact setup that you had
before
and like you'd have to
retune um one thing that you could
potentially do would be like
you could potentially like try to scale
them down equally and then increase the
learning rate by that same factor uh
though you might also have to change the
entropy stuff like entropy and value
rewards by the same factor there's a lot
of stuff that scales you're going to
have to try to scale everything like
together is the
thing cuz like let's say your rewards
are like 10 and 100 and then you go down
to like 0.1 and one okay now you have to
up the learning rate by a factor of 100
but the thing is you can't learn the
value function 100 times faster right
so like that has to now be decreased
like there's going to have to be some
tradeoff
there anyways dinner is here I got to go
uh I will be I think I'll be doing this
tomorrow as well so uh I think tomorrow
we'll see what else we finish up on the
environment and and uh maybe we'll get
neuron Nets training I think getting
neural Net's training would be really
cool though maybe we'll have to do some
balancing first I'll see anyways thank
you uh thank you all and I'll be back
tomorrow bye